Moin Leute
Test erfunst
Moin ja auf den letzten drücker machen wir heute mit dem Valomat für die für die
Wahl in hessen morgen also morgen ist es ja schon soweit am achten sonntag und ich habe noch gar nicht großartig reingeguckt
Ich habe auch echt keine ahnung was ich wählen soll ich finde alles irgendwie kacke
Ich glaube so geht es vielen deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir machen mal den Valomat nicht
dass ich was ich weiß nicht inwieweit ich
keine ahnung
mal gucken inwieweit mich das beeinflusst aber ich habe echt keine ahnung
mein opa hat immer gesagt man soll ungültig wählen aber eigentlich ist ungültig wählen auch bescheuert
das auch gleich kann es auch gleich sein lassen
Mr. Amek, danke für den Sub
Leute ich bin sowas von dead, geh alter, ich zeige euch mal was auf twitter haben es ja schon gesehen aber
Warte mal
Ich bin übertrieben dead
Mein bein
Also es tut jetzt nicht weh oder so also wenn ihr mich hier rumstöhnen hört gachi bass und so
Es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich ultra schmerzen hätte oder so, einfach einfach anstrengend gewesen
pass mal auf
wir gehen einfach wir gehen einfach auf nitter
besser als auf twitter direkt
ja leute ich bin richtig dead, geh, das ist eigentlich das was ich euch zeigen wollte
hyper dead, geh bin ich
ich bin heute ich bin auf dem fahrrad gefahren wieder mal
und zwar bin ich
okay nitter ist wieder absolut high speed seite
mw3 werbung wirklich vorm stream ja
Oh ja, ich werde es mir nicht kaufen, ehrlich ich werde es nicht kaufen
ich habe
ich bin mir gerade sicher ob ich mw2 überhaupt gekauft habe
habe ich mw2 gekauft, habe ich ein video dazu gemacht, ich weiß es gar nicht, ja ja ja ja doch doch doch doch habe ich
das game play
das fuckt mich einfach so krass ab in dem
also das generelle
new modern warfare game play, das remastered, reloaded, das game play fuckt mich einfach so ab
ich kann das nicht spielen, ich werde mir den 3er auch nicht kaufen
die kampagne finde ich auch nicht interessant, bisher war die call of duty kampagne immer irgendwie noch so ein bisschen
blockbuster mäßig gemacht
ich sehe auch weiterhin, aber ich glaube
ich habe, ich habe das einfach zu oft gespielt
so ähnliches zeug
ich, es interessiert mich überhaupt nicht
soll wie das alte sein, naja ganz bestimmt
man darf nicht vergessen, mw2, das erste mw2 hat schon game play technisch
extrem viel, ich meine, ich sage nur one man army noob tube
aber dual akimbo models
extrem viel gehabt, was abfuckt
auch das war auch damals schon extrem rum liga lastig
also, wobei, wobei
wir haben ja nicht rum gelegen, wir haben ja patrouilliert
das waren die zeiten, wo man den leuten noch erzählen konnte, ey
kauf dir ein gaming headset, und alle haben gesagt, boah max
krasser tipp, alter, gaming headset
wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt
ja, also was ich euch zeigen wollte
okay
not found, auch gut, nice
gg eats
also, man sieht es ja hier
guck mal, ich war heute, ich wollte eigentlich das eine bild ein bisschen vergrößern
ich wollte
fahrrad fahren, und zwar
51 km
3 stunden
der durchschnittsspeed ist jetzt nicht so geil
der durchschnittsspeed ist aber nicht so geil, weil
man sieht es hier
weil es den bank hochging
die hälfte der zeit, alter
und oben habe ich mich auch noch verfahren
guck mal, man sieht es hier
ich bin, ich bin hier runter gefahren
bin ich wieder hochgefahren
bin ich runter, habe ich auch gesehen, oh Mist, hier geht es nicht wieder lang
und dann bin ich wieder hochgefahren
also
das war echt anstrengend
also ungefähr
einmal so ein drittel, sieht man hier ungefähr
genau, ein drittel der zeit
war berghoch
und das war, da war ich richtig langsam
ich hatte da irgendwas um 7 kmh
oder so, ich bin übelst geschlichen
alter, das ist krass, ey
ich hätte es ja nicht gedacht
das meiste geht ja
aber das hat teilweise Anstiege drinnen
hier, sowas
die sind irgendwie 16% und die gehen nicht lang
die gehen so
keine Ahnung, 300 Meter
aber ich habe es nicht geschafft
ich habe es nicht
ich habe es nicht geschafft
die waden eher in den Oberschenkel
ich habe heute
auch gleich noch
eine Magnesiumpille genommen
aber Leute
das ist krass gewesen
teilweise 12, das war schon echt hart
aber 16%
da kommst du dir vor
das ist einfach eine steile, man
16% für 300 oder 300, 400 Meter
ich hätte es
fast hoch geschafft, die eine Rampe
aber
kurz bevor ich oben war
bin ich mit dem Fuß
quasi runtergerutscht
weil ich einmal konnte
das war echt krass, das hätte ich nicht gedacht
hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht
ich habe mich auch schon gewundert, wo die ganzen anderen Fahrradfahrer sind
und die sind einfach
die Straße nebendran gefahren
da ist es zwar ein bisschen länger
aber die geht nicht so steil hoch
naja
zumindest
war es dann am Ende
51 Kilometer
und 470 Höhenmeter
das mag jetzt
für Leute, die irgendwo
in Österreich wohnen oder sowas
nicht viel sein und da Fahrrad fahren
aber nachdem ich jetzt nicht der allergeübteste
Cyclist bin
Fahrradfahrer ist zu uncool
Cyclist
war das für mich echt anstrengend
die Durchschnitts
spiegelt das gar nicht so sehr wider
das Ding ist
berghoch war ich so im Arsch
ich hatte zwar nicht den
Ultrapuls, also ich hatte jetzt irgendwie nicht 170 plus
oder so
aber meine Oberschenkel haben es einfach nicht mitgemacht
Moin Nightrider
ich mache demnächst noch
wieder ein Video auf Youtube
ich wollte euch schon seit ewig meine Bewerbungsunterlagen zeigen
also natürlich ein bisschen anonymisiert
Arbeitszeugnis
meine Skillliste, mein Lebenslauf
ich habe es einfach noch nicht hingekriegt
zur Zeit
letzte Woche war witzig auf der Arbeit
also ich bin
ich bin hier
ich erzähl es euch jetzt
ich erzähl es einfach morgen früh
sind ja mehr Leute da
guck mal also
hab ich übrigens die richtige Kategorie
also
ich bin
wann war Tag der Deutschen Einheit
hier
Tag der Deutschen Einheit
also
es ist auch echt blöd
dass Tag der Deutschen Einheit immer am dritten ist oder
die sollten das so regeln
es ist immer am dritten
solange es nicht Montag ist
weil Montags bringen mir Feiertage nix
ich gette ja
dass Tag der Deutschen Einheit immer am Tag der Deutschen Einheit
sein müsste aber ich finde
wenn der Montag ist könnte man mal eine Ausnahme machen
dann
also Wochenende nicht
Samstag, Sonntag nicht und Montag nicht
an jedem anderen Tag ist es ok wenn der dritte ist
ansonsten müsste er verschoben werden
weil ich seh es nicht ein wenn ich eh frei hab
dass dann ein Feiertag ist
an Tagen wo ich eh frei hab Feiertage
sind einfach nur Sack
ja zumindest
was ganz witzig war
ich bin hier
am Freitag 29.
ja bin ich auch dafür
am 29.
also letzte Arbeitstag
also die Woche
letzte Woche
hab ich im Daily gesagt
es gibt so einen aktuellen
Projektplanungsplan
wo ich mitarbeite
auf der Arbeit
und da gab es so einen Punkt
in dieser Woche
soll
die Infrastruktur
die produktive
Infrastruktur für den Service aufgebaut werden
und ich hab am Freitag
ich hab im Donnerstag und am Freitag
hab ich auf unserem
super Hyper Agile Daily Scrum
schon gesagt Leute
also in Anbetracht der Tatsache dass das das und das
schwierig ist aktuell ich seh das
jetzt nicht wie das komplett passiert
nächste Woche
und dann wurde ich noch beruhigt von unseren Projektmanagern
die haben gesagt ah Max das ist nicht so schlimm
wir tun unser Bestes
und wenn das nicht klappt
dann korrigieren wir das ein bisschen nach hinten
macht ihr einfach mal
ich wollt's euch bloß sagen
also ne nicht dass es heißt ich hätt nichts gesagt oder so
und
dann war hier Samstag Sonntag
am Montag arbeite ich ja nicht
Dienstag war Tag der Deutschen Einheit
und am Mittwoch
bin ich wiedergekommen
und das erste was ich höre am Mittwoch ist
Max wie sieht's denn mit dem
Produktionsservice aus
Moment Leute also ihr erinnert euch
schon dran dass ich euch am Freitag erzählt habe
dass das schwierig wird mit dem
Produktionsservice und außerdem
außerdem hatten wir jetzt Wochenende
ich bin montags nicht da gewesen
der mein Teamkollege
der Infrastruktursachen macht das die ganze Woche nicht da
und Dienstag war Feierabend ich bin heute erst
wieder da
also nix mit dem
Produktionsservice ja aber
Max
schafft ihr das denn bis Freitag
oder hab ich nochmal gesagt
Leute Leute ich hab doch letzten Freitag
schon gesagt durch äußere
Einflüsse das und das und das
dass ich sehe da schwarz
dass das oh darf man das so sagen
also ich sehe da schwarz
dass das was wird
aber das müsste doch bis Freitag fertig werden
da muss ich halt fragen wie kommt's denn
auf einmal letzten Freitag habt ihr mir
doch noch gesagt ist alles kein Problem
da korrigieren wir halt den Projektplan ein bisschen
nach hinten und gut ist
und dann sind sie mit der Sprache rausgerückt
so ja
also einer unserer ich kann es jetzt nicht
nicht ganz so spezifisch
sagen ja
einer unserer Partner hat angefragt
ob sie diesen Service nicht mit benutzen können
und die wollen am 11.
quasi so eine Demosache machen
ach so
das ist ja gut
das ist ja richtig gut zu wissen
dass es am Freitag noch heißt kein Problem wir verschieben
es nach hinten und dann die zwei
die zwei Tage die man hat
und dann
hat man auf einmal bloß noch 1 2
3 4 Tage
bis irgendwelche Demos passieren sollen
ja alles klar
na gut wir probieren's mal
ich kann euch sagen der Status war
es hat noch niemand angefangen
mit dem
Live-Infrastrukturaufbau
und hier Anfang Mittwoch
war noch nicht mal die Testumgebung
funktionsfähig
die hab ich nämlich am Freitag abgebaut
vorher durfte ich nicht die hab ich am Freitag gelöscht
weil ich hab ein eigenes Terraform-Modul gebaut
für uns
wenn das so funktioniert
die komplette
Infrastruktur inklusive Datenbank
und ein paar
YAML-Configs die man braucht in den Cluster
reinhaut so dass
bei einem Neuaufbau alles da ist
und direkt drauf deployed werden kann
das muss man halt mal ausprobieren
dann will ich auch noch einrichten dass das einmal nachts
irgendwie einen Test-Cluster neu baut
und guckt ob alles funktioniert
so
und das heißt hier ging noch nicht mal die
Test-Infrastruktur zu dem Zeitpunkt
so und dann hab ich mich
zusammen hingesetzt
mit einem unserer
ne ist nicht wirklich Entwickler aber ich sag einfach mal Entwickler
dann wisst ihr was ich meine
mit einem unserer Entwickler
wir haben den ganzen
Mittwoch, äh den ganzen Donnerstag
da gesessen
und nichts anderes gemacht als unsere
Testumgebung gefixt
und jetzt um die ganze Sache nochmal einen oben drauf zu setzen
also
Mittwoch guck ich in meinen Kalender
und ich sehe
ich habe Mittwoch den ganzen Tag gemiete
inklusive einem halben Tag
Tagestermin
ich hab Donnerstag mehr oder weniger
den ganzen Tag gemiete
und den einzigen Tag der Woche
wo ich wirklich mal 4-5 Stunden vielleicht was machen kann
ist Freitag
und das hab ich dann auch so gesagt
ich kann die Woche vielleicht Freitag was machen
und
Mitt- und Donnerstag
Nachmittags kann ich auch nicht machen
weil da ist irgendwie eine IT-Abteilungsversammlung
da muss ich auch hin
so und jetzt haltet euch mal fest
man muss ja sagen unsere Projektmanager geben sich da schon Mühe
auf einmal ruft mich
mein Abteilungsleiter an
dem hab ich normalerweise
nicht so viel zu tun
und meinte so ach übrigens Max
wenn das im Projekt eng wird
ich kann dich von der Anwesenheitspflicht zur Abteilungsrunde
befreien
und da hab ich mir so gedacht
das ist wahrscheinlich keine schlechte Idee
das ist wahrscheinlich
keine schlechte Idee
da muss ich an dem Tag nicht sinnlos nach Frankfurt fahren
und ja
und ich soll mal bei mir im Team fragen
und sagen er hat das abgesegnet
dass ich auch Donnerstag
Freitag keine
ja
Ticket und Inzident
wie heißt das genau
weiß gar nicht ob wir da einen Namen für haben
also Ticket Monitoring und Inzident
Ansprechpartner machen muss
Donnerstag und Freitag morgen
hab ich auf mein Team gefragt
der Abteilungsleiter hat das abgesegnet
zack muss ich nichts machen
also da muss man sagen hey
da haben sich unsere Projektmanager tatsächlich Mühe gegeben
so bin ich
um eine Anwesenheitspflicht
bei der Abteilungsrunde rumgekommen
und das hat sich auch echt gelohnt
weil wir haben es doch tatsächlich geschafft
Donnerstag komplett
unsere komplette Testumgebung
neu hinzustellen
und am Freitag
jetzt kommt der Knaller
wir haben uns gedacht dann ist ja easy
die Live-Infrastruktur aufzubauen
weil wir haben jetzt ja das Terraform Modul
was alles hinstellt
also haben wir gemacht
Aufbau mit Terraform gar kein Problem
aber dann kam
paar unvorhergesehene Sachen noch dazwischen
und dann kam der Hammer
ich dachte mir so ah ja gut
komm lässt er halt
Terraform noch 2-3 mal durchlaufen
damit dieses Buggy Modul das macht was du willst
ok
und auf einmal konnte ich Terraform nicht mal laufen lassen
und da habe ich mir so gedacht
tech wait warum läuft Terraform auf einmal nicht mehr
und
es ist zeitgleich
während ich das ausführen wollte
unser Server
mit dem Main Software Repo vollgelaufen
und
nachdem das Terraform Modul
einen Helm install macht
und die Helmcharts auf diesem Main Repo Server liegen
hatte ich die Hälfte vom Freitag
keinerlei
also ab Freitag 13 Uhr
konnte ich kein Terraformer laufen lassen
weil der Main Repo Server weg war
also der Speicherplatz voll war
ups falsches E-Mail
ja
und
das habe ich dann halt
ich kann euch an der Stelle mal einen Tipp geben
wenn sowas vorkommt
versucht es nicht irgendwie zu fixen
weil ihr seid nicht dafür zuständig
es ist eine komplett andere Abteilung
ich meine wenn ihr was machen könnt macht es halt
aber versucht nicht irgendwie da rum zu nerven
zu fixen
sagt euren Projektleuten
ich kann nicht weitermachen
weil unser Repo Server nicht da ist
und dann können die sich irgendwo anders aufregen
oder halt einfach sagen ja passt schon
ich habe das auch weitergegeben
an unser Projektmanagement
und dann bin ich Freitag 14 Uhr 30 abgehauen
ich kann das auch nicht machen
und mal ne Runde rennen
den Satz verstehe ich nicht
was ist TBS
ach Terabyte meinst du
ach
das habe ich jetzt in dem Kontext nicht gecheckt
ja
ohne Mist Leute
das ist das einzige was ihr machen könnt
ihr könnt sagen das haut nicht hin
weil hier so viele andere Meetings
und wenn ich es wirklich ernst meine
dann sollen sie euch freistellen
ich bin auch einfach Donnerstag und Freitag
auf keine anderen Meetings mehr gegangen
und wenn einer gefragt hätte hätte ich gesagt
ja ich soll mich um eine Sache kümmern
sogar der Abteilungsleiter hat es abgesegnet
ich meine was willst du machen
wann geht es los
gleich
ein bisschen schwätzen
fang gleich an
ja
zumal ich es auch schon vorab gesagt habe
5 oder 10 Minuten fang mal an
das stimmt wohl
aber ich denke mir halt
ey wenn sie es so wollen
dann ist auch okay
letztendlich
die bezahlen mich
die können auch entscheiden was ich in der Zeit mache
ich meine wenn es gar so sehr gegen den Strich geht
dann kann ich es immer noch vom Acker machen
aber so sieht es wirklich aktuell nicht aus
ich finde es da viel viel angenehmer als im alten Laden
ey und
wenn die mir
110k im Jahr bezahlen wollen
ok auf 4 Tage runter gerechnet
für 60% meiner Zeit
da sitzen auf Meetings
dann mache ich das
easy gar kein Problem
sollen sie machen nicht mein Problem
also insofern
ja das gibt es immer
aber ich muss sagen das hält sich
ja wir haben auch im Team einen
der erzählt immer besonders viel und besonders gerne
ich kann mich da aber auch nicht ausnehmen ich mache das auch manchmal gerne
ja wir haben schon
bei manchen Meetings welche die haben
kennt ihr das?
irgendwelche Meetings
und so alle
einer sagt so hat noch jemand was
alle schweigen sich 2-3 Minuten an
und dann sagt er dann achja
dann würde ich sagen
haben wir es
sehen wir uns das nächste mal
und in dem Moment wo einer sagt ah dann haben wir es
kommt dann einer ah da fällt mir noch ein
das und das und das
die warten doch nur da drauf
die Woche neuen Job angefangen
und wie ist
oh mein Bobbes alter
ich muss sagen mein Hintern
man könnte auch sagen mein Arsch
ist deutlich
widerstandsfähiger schon gegen den
Sattel
ich muss jetzt sagen gegen den Sattel weil ansonsten
hätte sich das doch etwas
verkehrt angehört wenn ich gesagt hätte
mein Hintern ist jetzt deutlich widerstandsfähiger
wobei
2023 alles kein Problem
wenn es Spaß macht
zumindest
ich habe es heute gemerkt ich habe heute
3 Stunden im Sattel gehockt
hier 3 Minuten
3 Stunden 5 Minuten
und mein Bobbes tut nur
so
verhältnismäßig
wenig weh
und während dem Fahrrad fahre ich gar nicht
also
das muss ich sagen man gewöhnt sich echt an den Sattel
geht ganz gut
spielen mit dem Rose Backroad
ja
schaltet die elektronische Schaltung ordentlich
ja ja
das einzige was ich noch mal machen muss
ich muss wahrscheinlich mal morgen
hinten
noch mal die
Bremse
wie heißt das
Scheibenbremse
nein Felgenbremse
ja ich habe sogar welche
aber die habe ich noch nicht benutzt
ich muss morgen hinten die Bremse
noch mal ein bisschen justieren
weil heute bin ich den Berg runter gefahren
hier das hier
hier bin ich runter gefahren
und da musstest du halt konstant für
naja was ist denn das hier
20 Minuten oder so
da musstest du halt konstant bremsen
für 20 Minuten
also manchmal konntest du es auch ordentlich
runter rollen lassen aber oft
musst du halt durch die Ortschaft durch
ich kann euch übrigens zeigen
wo ich gefahren bin
zumindest geht es da halt übelst runter
und ich habe heute zum ersten
mal so richtig die Bremse heiß gebremst
ja dadurch
und
da habe ich auch gemerkt
hinten schleift es ein bisschen wenn die richtig
heiß wird ich meine klar das dehnt sich aus
muss ich auch morgen gucken ob das noch da ist
und
wenn ja muss ich hier noch mal kurz ein bisschen justieren
da gibt es übrigens einen nice Trick
wie man seine Scheibenbremse
justiert
man muss die einfach ein bisschen locker
schrauben
und dann bremsen und die Bremse gedrückt
halten und festschrauben dann zieht sich
das meisten selbst in die richtige Pose
Test in production naja klar habe ich die vorher getestet
ich habe jetzt nicht
bin ja nicht berghoch gefahren und dazu habe ich zum ersten
mal gebremst bergrunter
ja
ich gebe dir mal einen Tipp
wenn du mehrere Stunden stehen musst
kauf dir
Schuhe mit Dämpfung
kauf dir zum Beispiel
äh kauf dir zum Beispiel so einen
hier
guck mal
da hast du richtig nice
Dämpfung
das bringt auch im Stehen was
also natürlich
musst du da manchmal was machen
deswegen kannst du die ja auch abschrauben
wenn du nie was machen müsstest
macht es ja auch keinen Sinn dass das schrauben hat
wo du das justieren kannst
also ich hatte das ganze am Anfang am Vorderrad
da hatten sie es dann richtig dran geschraubt
das habe ich einmal
so ausgerichtet wie beschrieben
mal gucken ich meine es kann auch einfach sein
dass es hinten super heiß geworden ist
ich glaube wir reden von was anderem
nein
da traue ich mich noch nicht
ja ich kann euch wie gesagt ich kann euch zeigen
wenn ihr wollt wo ich gefahren bin
google maps
hier bin ich gefahren
kann man den
und zwar
kann google irgendwie Höhenprofile oder so
bist du allein gefahren
ja
ähm
hier ist auch so ein Turm normalerweise
genau hier ist der Turm da bin ich hingefahren
was denn
grad fahren oder
ich fände es cool wenn man sich ein Profil anzeigen lassen könnte
so sagen wir jetzt mal
von hier
machen wir mal so
ja das trifft ganz gut
weil ich gefahren bin
also ich bin natürlich von Hanau aus gefahren
aber das ist jetzt so
das hier ist so quasi der
der Anstieg den ich gefahren bin
ich zeige euch das wir machen
Leute wir machen mal Streetview
ich zeige euch wo ich gefahren bin
so ähm
ja genau
naja gut das ist jetzt für Auto
wir machen das mal für Fahrrad
äh
was auch immer google dafür
merkwürdige
ja
das ist so bin ich gefahren
so also von hier
nach da genau so
achtung
oh ne
oh ne es gibt kein
no es gibt
es gibt kein Streetview
shit
äh oder doch
ich bin ich bin verwirrt
doch hier hier gibt es doch
hier gibt es doch
Moment äh
hey ich will da lang
hier gibt es
kein Streetview
kann man hier hochfahren
ne hier gibt es nicht
hier gibt es kein Streetview
gibt es hier oben irgendwo
Streetview irgendwas hier
nein
kein ok wir haben
es gibt kein Streetview ich hätte es euch gezeigt aber
kein kein Streetview
kein Streetview
wir können noch mal maps
ne äh earth
google hier sieht man es glaube ich
auch ganz gut ja
ah hier sieht man es ganz
äh ok
also
man konnte den Krempel doch irgendwie kippen oder
so also guck hier seht ihr
hier den Weg bin ich runter
raufgefahren
kommt hier der Parkplatz
irgendwo
aber man erkennt es nicht richtig gut
und hier
äh ich will 3D
will ich 3D viel geiler
das hier ist Leute
das man
sieht das nicht man sieht das nicht richtig
ey
das hier ist so krass
steil dieses Stück
ne ne das macht keinen Unterschied
es kippt einfach nur
oh guck mal da gibt es
ein
ich bin bei dem im Klo
man warum
zum
warum
bin ich bei dem Typ im Klo jetzt
zum Glück
steht er hier nackig rum
zu geil
random Klo Bild
zumindest
worauf ich eigentlich rausfalle
Leute dieses Stück hier
das ist so brutal
steil
Moment ich glaube ich bin
ich bin so
das ist verkehrt
das Stück hier das meine ich
das ist so übelst steil
das geht
das geht von
genau von hier
das geht hier 16% hoch
16% Leute
das sind nur
300 Meter oder so
aber Leute ich bin verreckt
ich bin halb verreckt dabei
16% ist mega krass
das halte ich
nicht aus
ja man sieht es leider nicht gescheit
gibt es sonst noch irgendwelche Bilder
wenn man da mal
google
google was jetzt
so hier gibt es das Bad
von dem Typ
wie hätte es sonst noch keine
irgendwelche Bilder gemacht oder wie
ok google
ist mal wieder recht pepega unterwegs
ja gut hier gibt es
hier oben gibt es halt Bilder
hier oben gibt es halt Bilder vom Turm
und so wo man
da war ich heute
hier oben war ich heute
von da bin ich gekommen
welcher Ort
was ist das hier
das ist
massive
das ist Hemsbach
das hat glaube ich
keine Ahnung
70 Einwohner oder so
ja wobei
Moment ne ne ne Hemsbach hat glaube ich
sogar 150 oder so
es gibt da noch Klein Hemsbach
das hat irgendwie 80 oder so
ja ganz kleines
ganz kleines
nächstes mal fahre ich anders
nächstes mal fahre ich nicht mehr hier diese
Main Street
da fahre ich die Straße
hier bloß bis da
dann fahre ich da rauf
Klein Hemsbach
fahre hier durch
und fahre dann
irgendwie
irgendwie hier hinten oder so rum
weil
das ist mir einfach zu steil
das pack ich nicht
aber schade
dass es kein Google Street View gibt
sonst hätte ich euch die Straße
gezeigt das ging wirklich krass rauf
Razer danke für den Sub
und ich hab bestimmt noch irgendwas übersehen
ReligionSmith danke für den Sub
Pog
hast du was gegessen
ein Mr. Tom
kennt ihr Mr. Tom
Mr. Tom
hab ich gefuttert
ja klar
erstmal die Tupperbox mitgenommen aufs Fahrrad
Mr. Amek
danke für den Sub
weiß nicht ob ich es schon gesagt hab
aber wer kann es ja nicht oft genug sagen
Pog
Map
das kann ich nicht mal aussprechen
ja mach ich auch
ich hab sogar eine GoPro gekauft
nur 150
Leute wenn man das nicht gewöhnt ist
ich hab es heute wieder gemerkt
berghoch ist einfach brutal
Mapillary
ich bin
ich bin zu dumm das auszusprechen
Kartendaten erkunden
ok probieren wir das mal hier aus
also
Alzenau
Hanenkamm
ja meinetwegen
wow
das war aber falsch will ich nicht hin
äh
ok
Hemsbach
Alzenau
Mömpris
ach guck mal die haben Bilder
ah ja guck mal
oder
ne
ne die haben auch keine Bilder
oder wie oder was
oder doch
ne doch die haben Bilder oder
ja genau so gut
und wie funzt das jetzt
kann man das groß machen
ah ja
äh
äh Leute
wie navigate ich hier
ich
hab Schwierigkeiten mich zu orientieren grade
äh
ach das sind keine 360 Kameras
oder
die Kamera ist halt ein bisschen
ein bisschen schepp ne
so
genau hier gehts
also hier gings schon ordentlich rauf
ja man siehts hier schon
also hier gings schon ein bisschen rauf aber
so jetzt gehts gleich
richtig los
so hier genau
oh ne hier ist fertig
hä
was
das ist doch kacke
da sieht man doch gar nix
ich weiß doch nicht mal ob ich
richtig fahre überhaupt
Moment hä
das suckt man
Ultramann
und wie komm ich jetzt zurück
auf die Map Übersicht
boah ich hab schon wieder keinen Bock
auf den Service
das geht einfach nur zur Seite
das ist ja
ne das ist ja der Weg den ich hochgefahren bin
leider
leider gibt es hier nur Bilder
ach ab und zu
ab und zu gibt es
ach guck mal ab und zu gibt es mal Bilder nach vorne
riecht
richtig pipega
man
ja guck mal hier
hä
jetzt weiß ich auch
warum sich Google Maps durchsetzt und nicht
irgendwelche anderen Services
also hier gehts recht
oh was jetzt
also ihr seht hier geht es
hier geht es relativ
guck mal hier haben wir noch ein Bild vorwärts
hier gehts
relativ
warum kann man
kann man jetzt hier weiter
ach hier kann man so weitermachen
ihr seht also da geht es doch
da geht es doch recht steil rauf
aber das ist doch nicht das steilste Stück
so hier ist ne Baustelle
hier war es schon relativ anstrengend
ja
hier war es schon relativ anstrengend rauf
also ihr seht schon hier auch
wenn man sich hier neben die Straße anguckt
also ab hier
habe ich richtig gut geschnauft
ja geht noch ordentlich rauf
und jetzt ich hoffe die haben das super
steile Stück drin
es kommt jetzt gleich da vorne
ja hier
erst nochmal durch
das hier ging es ein bisschen
3-4% oder so
das ging jetzt
hat Bing Street View
ich glaube nicht
und jetzt kommt es
wenn man hier vorbei ist
sonst ist man
hier Leute seht ihr es hier vorne
hier vorne muss ich rauf
man sieht es hier noch
hier
man hat halt mal wieder
jetzt
das sind 16%
und jetzt hier rechts rum
jetzt hier rechts rum
aber rechts rum
und jetzt
und hier jetzt rechts rum da geht es weiter nochmal
irgendwie mit 16%
aber man sieht es leider nicht
Leute ich war so im Arsch
das nächste mal fahre ich auch so
wie die hier ich fahre außen rum
so und dann
ja
ach guck mal hier hört alles auf
hier ist der Parkplatz und dann geht es hier hoch
naja gut
Apple Karten geht online glaube ich nicht
oder
naja
es war wirklich echt
anstrengend
mir tun sogar
eigentlich würde man sagen mir tun nur die Beine weh
mir tun sogar die Ärmel weh
vom ziehen am Lenker
ey
Dr. Go hat Apple
echt
ich habe keine Ahnung
ich probiere das jetzt mal aus
Dulles International Airport
ok wo auch immer ich hier gerade
gelandet bin
Möbris
ja
aber hier gibt es keine
ja aber die haben den Street View
die haben den Street View
Part nicht
aber die haben
die haben auf jeden Fall einen besseren
Winkel gewählt
für die
aber auf jeden Fall krass
so dann geben wir uns mal den
Valumat
45 Minuten geschwätzt
also
ich habe auch gemerkt
es geht nicht nur
ultra auf die Beine
auch weil man sich halt
je nachdem weil man so lange
auf dem Lenker sitzt
am Lenker sitzt nicht auf dem Lenker sitzt
es geht
auch echt in die
in die Handballen
und sowas wenn man da so drauf hängt
ich habe mir extra noch ein paar Handschuhe gekauft
die ein bisschen gepolstert sind
aber ich merke es jetzt schon
hast du Golos Video?
ja habe ich gesehen
jetzt gucke ich mir aber nicht im Stream an
ist mir peinlich
ich habe das ja überhaupt nicht
gewusst dass das bei ihm so ein halbes
Kindheitstrauma ist mit seinen Augen
sonst hätte ich ihn nicht
sonst hätte ich das
nicht erzählt
ich habe das ja nicht erzählt um ihn jetzt irgendwie zu ärgern
einfach das ist
mir aufgefallen ich fand das lustig
kann man
nicht wissen
ich glaube er ist auch nicht so in dem
ganzen Twitch
Twitch Speak Sache so drin
aber trotzdem ich kann es ja verstehen
das war wirklich keine Absicht
ich habe es nämlich auch als Kommentar drunter geschrieben
es tut mir jetzt echt leid
dass ich
ich habe da jetzt schon ein bisschen schlechtes Gewissen
dass das so komplett
einen Falschen erwischt hat
irgendwie aber
ich wusste es halt echt nicht
ich dachte
ich dachte dass es ungefähr auf dem Niveau
wie der Max hat dicke Arme oder sowas
da war ich ja auch drüber lustig
kann sich ja der ein oder andere daran erinnern
aber halt ohne dass ich das jetzt super
schlimm finde oder so
aber man weiß es halt nicht
so also dann
Chatgy
geht ihr morgen wählen?
Hessen
Wahlen 2023
Landtagswahl
in Hessen
Hessen und Bayern
ich glaube Bayern ist auch morgen
ja
und wann ist die?
Datum
auch 8. Oktober
ich habe keine Ahnung warum
aber irgendwie mag ich die nicht
also ich bin ja öfters mal in Bayern
wie ihr heute auch wieder gesehen habt
hier an den Karten
also was mir in Bayern auffällt
die haben so eine komische
Bayern Partei
die heißt doch die Bayern Partei oder sowas
und da steht dann so
Zeug auf dem Plakat drauf
äh jetzt reichts
Berlin die Bayern Partei
und sowas wo ich mir so
ok was wollt ihr genau?
also ich hab aus den Plakaten
noch nicht erkannt
was die eigentlich wollen
ich mein da wird immer viel gelabert und im Endeffekt
wenig gemacht
die wollen sich
legit von Deutschland abspalten
also die wollen
dass Bayern quasi ein eigenes Land wird oder was
nein
ja die CSU gibt es auch aber
es gibt echt in Bayern eine Partei
die heißt wohl
ich kenne das so von Plakaten wenn ich in Bayern unterwegs bin
die Bayern Partei
und die haben glaube ich gefühlt auch nur
ein Plakaten da steht drauf jetzt reichts Berlin
nein ich meine
ich meine wirklich
die heißen die Bayern Partei
ich kenne das nur
halt von den Plakaten
die
wo hab ichs denn jetzt hier offen
nur von den Plakaten die in Bayern rumhängen
und das Söder grinst mich
öfters an in Bayern von irgendwelchen Plakaten
BBG
gabs nicht als für ein Plakat
hab ich
freie Wähler hab ich glaube ich in Bayern
noch nicht gesehen
und in Hessen tatsächlich
ich weiß vielleicht sogar mehr
als in Hessen
weil
wenn ich wandern gehe ist das oftmals in Bayern
und da laufe ich an bayerischen Plakaten vorbei
ansonsten juckt mich das ja
alles nur
am Rande auch wenn es dann vielleicht mehr jucken sollte
mich juckt das alles
wenig ich hab mich schon von dem Gedanken
verabschiedet
dass irgendjemand irgendwas für mich umsetzt
beziehungsweise für mich macht was mir gefällt
mit meinem Geld
deswegen
geht mir das eigentlich alles ein bisschen
am Arsch vorbei und ich versuch so gut wie möglich
das Beste für mich rauszuholen
und auf alles andere zu scheißen
ich weiß ist jetzt vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen
tja
weiß ich pp-iger Einstellung
aber da bin ich mittlerweile angekommen
ich verlass mich nicht mehr drauf
dass irgendeiner mal irgendwas macht was in meinem Sinne ist
egal wer
Moin Vegan Nico
so also da gucken wir uns das mal an
was uns jetzt versprochen wird
muss man ja auch immer sehen
was da erzählt wird
was da erzählt wird ist wahrscheinlich
eh nur die
wird wahrscheinlich nur ein Bruchteil davon
dann auch wirklich angegangen und gemacht
also schauen wir mal
Hessenwahl 2023
ist das jetzt eigentlich schwarz
weil Dark Mode
oder ist das immer schwarz
schon auf
CSU, CDU wählen
vorbereiten
ja passt mal auf ist das vielleicht
richtig High IQ Webseite
die mein
Betriebssystem
ausliest und deswegen
den Hintergrund schwarz macht
das ist wahrscheinlich auch
High Contrast das es auch die Rentner lesen können
TopTopTV
danke schön für den Sub
ok also
let's go
meine Hand tut weh
3 Stunden länger
festkrallen sind doch ein bisschen viel
also
schauen wir mal was ist denn die erste Frage
wählen mit 16
Jugendliche sollen bei Landtagswahl
ab 16 Jahren wählen dürfen
ok da bin ich prinzipiell dafür
sollte Dark Mode System
sein ja da bin ich prinzipiell
dafür das einzige warum ich
ein bisschen skeptisch bin ist
ich weiß nicht ob man das so ohne weiteres umsetzen
kann weil ich bilde mir ein
dass ich mal irgendwo einen Artikel drüber
gelesen habe dass das
rechtlich so ohne
Gesetzesänderung und
wohl recht tiefgreifende Gesetzesänderung gar nicht
geht aber prinzipiell finde ich
das gut weil
da können die ganzen Leute die
erzählen so nach dem Motto oh
die ganzen alten Leute entscheiden nur
und die machen eh alle
scheiße und wir dürfen
nicht und so da können die einfach wählen gehen
und gut ist es wird sich im Prinzip
wahrscheinlich an der Gesamt
wer wie viel Prozent bekommt
dadurch dass die Leute 2 Jahre wählen dürfen
früher wählen dürfen wahrscheinlich so gut wie nichts
ändern also ich stimme
der Sache mal zu ich finde das eigentlich nicht schlecht
Hessen soll sich für den Abzug der im Land
stationierten US Strahlkräfte einsetzen
also ich bin aufgewachsen
hier in der Zeit also gerade in Hanau da hatten wir
sehr viele Kasernen und die meisten
Sachen die meisten sind ja schon weg
Kona Time
die meisten sind ja schon weg
ob jetzt die paar
die noch da sind
auch noch ein bisschen länger
da bleiben
ist mir eigentlich vollkommen egal
können ruhig da bleiben
so einer meiner besten Bekannten
von der Arbeit ist Ami so halb
halbe halbe halbe halbe
ähm und er war auch bei der
Armi wer weiß wenn sein
Vater nicht hier gibts den gar nicht also
ganz ehrlich die paar die noch
da sind die können aus meiner Sicht auch ruhig da bleiben
nein stimme ich nicht zu
Eltern sollen sich weiter
an den Kosten für das Schulessen beteiligen
müssen okay ich wusste
gar nicht dass das zur Debatte steht
ich hab da jetzt meine
blöde Frage warum nicht
was ist so verwerflich daran dass die Eltern
ihren Kindern irgendwie zwei Brötchen mitgeben
in die Schule also ich hab
früher zwei Brötchen und ein Kakao mitgekriegt
kenn ihr diese diese
diese Plastik
diese Plastik Kakao
Tetra Pak Dinger
diese Plastik Kakao Päckchen
und
was wir damit immer gemacht haben ist
es geht um gratis
Mittagessen
ich hab in der Schule nie Mittag gegessen
ich hab ich hab da ein Brötchen
ich hab Mittagessen
ich hab da ein Brötchen
ich hab morgens daheim schnell was gegessen
dann bin ich in die Schule gefahren
ich mein das war zum größten Teil war das
bis auf paar Tage war das 13 Uhr
13 Uhr 5 glaube ich fertig
paar Tage später gab es
da war man aber auch schon ne ganze Ecke älter
gab es dann teilweise
bis Nachmittag
aber ich hab dann
zwei Brötchen gefuttert
gut ist
Essen ohne allen
für mehr Kosten ist doch nice
ich bin da mein die Leute können sich
können sich da ruhig dran
beteiligen
weil das ganze Bildungssystem
pfeift im Endeffekt eh schon auf dem letzten Loch
und
noch mehr Verwaltung und noch mehr
Kohle weiß ich nicht ob das so sinnvoll ist
und ich war in den
Kindern 2-3 Brötchen mitgeben
zumindest was ich sagen wollte zu dem Kakaopäckchen
wir waren ja damals
richtige Assis in der Schule ja
und
wir haben teilweise in der
wir haben diese Kakaopäckchen genommen
haben die also ich war nicht der einzige
der so Kakaopäckchen dabei hatte
und wir haben die dann leer gesoffen
bis so noch ein Viertel drinnen war
und dann
sind wir in irgendeine Ecke
gegangen wo andere Leute waren
die wir ärgern wollten sind auf das Kakaopäckchen
draufgesprungen und hat das Kakaopäckchen
dann so richtig schön gemacht
und hat in einem ungefähr
tja weiß nicht so
Kegelradius kann man nicht sagen
Kegelförmig
circa 10 Meter weit den Kakao
gespritzt quer über den Schulhof
und dann mussten wir aber wegrennen
weil das war strengstens verboten
und die Lehrer haben auch
danach geguckt und da gab es richtig
Ärger teilweise wenn du erwischt wurdest
musste sogar
Hausordnung abschreiben dafür schon
Glasflaschen hätte es nicht
hätte es nicht gegeben
wir haben Kakao rumgespritzt
ich weiß noch es war das einzige Mal
wo ich die Hausordnung abschreiben musste
ich hab das sogar gemacht
theoretisch sind es ja solche Aufgaben wo man sich
sogar beschweren kann dass man die nicht machen will
oder sowas
ähm
ey das kannst du mir heute nicht vorwerfen ich hab
selbst genug Kakao abgekriegt
also ja schon aber ich hab es auch abgekriegt
insofern
gut also ich find das nicht verkehrt
dass die Eltern ihren Kindern
Essen mitgeben
und wenn in der Schule gekocht wird
ich mein seriously was wird denn
passieren
wenn die
dann wird in irgendeiner Art und Weise die Gebühr erhöht
was inklusive sein muss
letztendlich werden es eh wieder die Eltern bezahlen
ja
ich find das eigentlich ganz sinnvoll
das Nachtflugverbot
am Frankfurter
das ist ein Thema ohne Scheiß Leute
seit ich klein bin
das ist wahrscheinlich
schon davor seit ich mich erinnern
kann es gibt es
permanent Diskussionen
Ausbau Frankfurt
Nachtflugverbot Frankfurt
und ja ich gätte dass es mega
beschissen ist am Frankfurter Flughafen
zu wohnen und dem Fluglärm
ausgesetzt zu sein
aber trotzdem das ist ein ganz kleiner Teil
von Leuten und
für die ist es scheiße ja das verstehe ich
aber der Frankfurter Flughafen ist so
ziemlich eines der wichtigsten Sachen die wir
in der Region haben und alles was
denen äh kastriert weiter
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
find ich nicht sinnvoll
die Kohlekraftwerke in
Hessen sollen auch nach 2023
weiterbetrieben werden
nö
sollen sie nicht
ich mein es ist immer ein bisschen
wie sagen wir so
situationsabhängig also
wenn wir es bis 2028
nicht geschafft haben in irgendeiner Art
und Weise autark und
unabhängig zu sein mit
nicht Kohlekraft
produzierter Energie
dann kann das durchaus vereinzelt
Sinn machen aber ich denke nicht
dass wir jetzt sagen sollen naja gut wir machen das schon mal
in
antizipieren wir bekommen es nicht auf die Reihe
also insofern
ich glaube zwar nicht dass wir die Welt retten
können mit Energiewende bei uns
und
quasi alles der Sache unterordnet
bin ich auch nicht kein großer Fan
von aber trotzdem
das da bin ich nicht dafür
also irgendwann muss auch mal Schluss sein
damit und sollte es
situationsbedingt noch sein müssen
dann kann man sich das 2028
überlegen ob man da irgendwann
aber nicht jetzt schon
die Kohlekraftwerke sollen auch
ich muss immer gucken dass ich das Richtige abstimme
die Kohlekraftwerke in Hessen sollen auch
nach 2038
weiterbetrieben werden
nein stimme ich nicht zu
das Land Hessen soll ausreisepflichtige
Ausländerinnen und Ausländer
konsequent abschieben da stimme ich tatsächlich
zu weil wer ausreisepflichtig
ist hat alle Rechtswege in Deutschland
in Anspruch genommen
und tschüss
Hessen soll nur noch ökologische
Landwirtschaft fördern
keine Ahnung ich meine
auf der einen Seite würde ich da zustimmen
auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir
ich will jetzt nicht der Marktregel
das den FDP Spruch oder sowas bringen
aber auf der anderen Seite
denke ich mir
ich weiß nicht ob Förderung immer so sehr
keine Ahnung
es muss sich halt im Endeffekt
rechnen und lohnen also ich denke
es hat wenig Sinn wenn es ganz viele
Betriebe gibt die nur über die Runden kommen
weil sie irgendwelche Förderungen bekommen
und der Rest
eigentlich
gar nicht betreibbar wäre
ich weiß es nicht
keine Ahnung
da würde ich tatsächlich mal neutral stimmen
ich
Chat sagt ökologische Landwirtschaft
ist nicht immer besser für die Umwelt
tja man weiß ja nicht
wie das ausgelegt wird
ich stimme neutral
ich weiß es nicht
keine Ahnung
genau dieses nur noch stört mich auch
also wenn man jetzt sagen würde okay
man soll vermehrt drauf achten
das fände ich okay aber es kann ja durchaus
situationsbedingt immer
Sinn machen
ich finde generell solche 0 oder 100%
oder alles oder nichts Regelungen
in den meisten Fällen
halt nicht ganz realitätspassend
man kann ja durchaus sagen man wirkt darauf hin
oder man möchte dass es so und so im größten Teil
der Fälle ist aber manchmal
gibt es halt doch sinnvolle Ausnahmen
egal ich war mal neutral
ich weiß es nicht
das Landesamt für
Verfassungsschutz Hessen soll aufgelöst
werden
steht das zur Diskussion
warum
ich meine okay gehen wir mal von aus
gehen wir mal davon aus
das Land
das will bestimmt die AfD oder sowas
das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht
ich meine gehen wir mal davon aus
das Landesamt
für Verfassungsschutz
Hessen soll aufgelöst
gehen wir mal davon aus es wird aufgelöst
dann gibt es irgendeine andere
Institution die das
macht und dann gibt es dann wieder
irgendwelche Stellen zu besetzen
und irgendwelche
Dinger die gedreht werden also das was danach
kommt muss nicht unbedingt
besser sein
wahrscheinlich
sogar noch schlimmer
keine Ahnung also
ich hätte echt absolut keine Ahnung warum das
aufgelöst werden soll
nein das soll nicht aufgelöst werden
vielleicht geht das in die Richtung
dass wir nur noch eins anstatt 16
ich habe keine Ahnung aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht
warum das aufgelöst werden sollte
ja und die haben wahrscheinlich alle auch schon
irgendwann scheiße gebaut
aber ob das
wie gesagt wenn das weg ist kommt
irgendwas anderes ist wahrscheinlich noch beschissener
ok
Hessen soll die Begrenzung der Neuverschuldung
Schuldenbremse einhalten
ne
die sollen das machen was wirtschaftlich
sinnvoll ist und das ist nicht unbedingt immer
ähm
Schuldenbremse
das sagt bestimmt die FDP auch
ähm
ne
nicht unter allen Bedingungen
das letzte Kita-Jahr vor der Einschulung
soll in Hessen für alle Kinder verpflichtend sein
ok ich glaube das
zielt in die Richtung
Kinder sollen halt
deutsch sprechen können wenn sie in die Schule kommen
und das finde ich sinnvoll
also ich habe letztens irgendwo
einen Beitrag zu
Artikel dazu gelesen
dass das wohl gerade in der Grundschule richtig
großes Problem ist
dass eine nicht unerhebliche Zahl der
Grundschüler nicht richtig
Deutsch kann
also weiß ich
keine Ahnung ob das so wirklich da was dran ändert
ne Kindergarten ist nicht
Pflicht musst du nicht
außerdem muss man erstmal
einen Kita-Platz bekommen genau
es gibt schon so viele die
damit Probleme haben also
ob das wirklich was bringt
dass sie besser Deutsch können also man könnte
vielleicht sagen so nach dem Motto
ja gut
da müsstest du wieder irgendwelche Sonderfälle
machen für alle die nicht Deutsch können oder so
ist natürlich auch doof
also wenn die sagen würden
so nach dem Motto ok wir schaffen jetzt
zeitgleich auch mehr Plätze
dass alle Kinder
also prinzipiell finde ich die Idee
dass Kinder mal bevor sie in die Schule kommen
Kontakt mit der Umwelt hatten
gar nicht so blöd
ja also
ich finde es gar nicht so
verkehrt
ich stelle mir es aber schwierig
vor wie man das umsetzen will
ich stimme mal zu
ich bin mir da aber echt
unsicher wie sie das machen wollen
und ob das überhaupt in die Richtung ausgelegt
ist wie ich mir das jetzt vorstelle
das steht ja nochmal auf einem ganz anderen Zettel
wir gucken uns am Ende noch an was die unterschiedlichen
Parteien dazu gesagt haben warum sie das wollen
und warum sie das nicht wollen
ich stimme der Sache mal zu
soll weitere Medizinstudien Plätze
für Menschen geben die sich verpflichten später
als Ärztin oder Arzt
ach auf dem Land zu arbeiten
wollte gerade sagen
das klingt doch erstmal sinnig
die FDP würde jetzt
sagen der Markt regelt das
ich finde
das klingt irgendwie ganz sinnig
ohne mich jetzt
weiter mit dem Thema
beschäftigt zu haben was da die
Nachteile dran sind also
ich finde das klingt
erstmal ganz sinnvoll
zumal es auf dem Land wohl richtig Probleme gibt
vielleicht sollte man das Ganze
für Tierärzte auch noch machen
es soll attraktiver gemacht werden
auf dem Land zu arbeiten das ist halt das Ding
ich denke nicht
dass das dazu führt
dass es attraktiver wird auf dem Land
zu arbeiten
das führt dazu dass sich Leute verpflichten
und damit noch einen Studienplatz bekommen
sie können ihre Zeit auf dem Land absitzen und wieder abhauen
wenn es nicht attraktiv ist
auf dem Land zu arbeiten
die Schweizer Version
ich mache gerne die Schweizer Version
wenn es sowas gibt weil davon habe ich noch weniger Plan
also
das ist so ein typisches Ding
ich glaube das hört sich erstmal gut an
ob das
wirklich die
die Probleme löst
wenn es prinzipiell nicht attraktiv ist auf dem Land zu arbeiten
ist
fraglich
weil seriously was passiert
mal angenommen die Leute haben keinen Bock auf dem Land zu arbeiten
dann
sitzen die ihre Zeit ab und hauen danach wieder ab
aber es schadet auf jeden Fall auch nichts
also ich finde es eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt
ich stimme der Sache mal zu
Empfängerinnen und Empfängern von Bürgergeld
sollen Leistungen gekürzt werden wenn sie Jobangebote ablehnen
ok
da bin ich jetzt ein bisschen gespalten
und zwar
das ist so der Unterschied von
was ich persönlich
ja empfinde
und was ich mir logisch
zusammen reiben kann
also persönlich
meiner persönlichen Empfindung nach
weil ich da auch schon mal kurzzeitig davon betroffen
betroffen
betroffen war
also jetzt nicht mit kürzen aber generell
mit Arbeitsamt und sowas
mein persönliches Gefühl sagt
nein sollte nicht aber
mein logisches drüber nachdenken
sagt ja
weil
es braucht ja
in irgendeiner Art und Weise einen Anreiz
das zu machen
also
was arbeiten zu gehen
also wenn es zu easy ist
wie hieß dieser Typ
der auch öfters mal
in der Bild Zeitung war als
Deutschlands längster Arbeitsloser oder sowas
ja genau der Typ
also wenn es
zu easy ist
quasi
Geld zu bekommen und abzuchillen
dann ist das auch nicht gut
also das ist halt echt so eine Frage
persönlich
würde ich also gefühlsmäßig
würde ich sofort sagen nein stimme ich nicht zu
jetzt aber logisch drüber nachgedacht
finde ich ist das nicht unwichtig
dass es einen gewissen
gewissen Druck gibt
doch was zu machen
dass das nicht komplett aus dem Ruder läuft
ja was mache ich denn
jetzt
sollte es nicht eher positive Reize geben
es gibt ja positive Reize die Leute können
normales Leben führen
sich ein bisschen was leisten
aber für manche reicht das ja anscheinend
also ich weiß nicht
da bin ich echt
nee nee nee wir machen keine Abstimmung
ich muss ja morgen wählen
ich könnte neutral sagen
also gefühlsmäßig würde ich sagen
stimme ich nicht zu
so rational
drüber nachgedacht würde ich sagen stimme ich zu
ich mach mal neutral
beim Ausbau der Verkehrsinfrastruktur
soll die Schiene Vorrang fordern
ja auf jeden Fall
es ist zwar unrealistisch
das gebe ich zu dass das passieren wird
aber ihr wisst
also ich bin nun wirklich
kein Bahnfan
aber ich denke bei alledem
was sich so abzeichnet
brauchen wir ein ordentlich ausgebauten
öffentlichen Nahverkehr
und auch ein Schienennetz
ich meine es wird heutzutage schon drüber
diskutiert
ob es ein Autoverbot
in Innenstädten geben soll
das war vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
vielleicht erinnert sich noch einer
war das ja mal wirklich für Frankfurt im Gespräch
das wollten ja mal ein paar Leute
also es war mal im Gespräch
denke ich mir so ey
nicht generell
das Autoverbot sondern so nach dem Motto
ich glaube es ging sogar drum
Verbrennerautoverbot in Innenstädten
also das Ding ist halt
du kannst nicht was verbieten
bevor Alternativen da sind
und außerdem finde ich generell bei sowas
Verbote sollte es aber so
das letzte Mittel sein
wenn es nämlich einen gut ausgebauten Nahverkehr gibt
gehe ich stark von aus
also wenn das auch funktioniert
es reicht ja nicht wenn es einfach ausgebaut wird
es ist danach immer noch alles scheiße
ich meine ich glaube
die Bahn kriegt das hin
ausgebaut und trotzdem scheiße sein
aber es wird
auf jeden Fall dazu führen
wenn das gut funktioniert
wenn du dich drauf verlassen kannst
es kommt öfters was
du musst da nicht irgendwie
laufen in die App gucken sondern du kannst sagen
ach ich würde jetzt gerne mal
nach Frankfurt noch irgendwas
Fahrradklamotten kaufen oder irgendwas
und dann setzt du dich mal kurz in den Zug
fährst nach Frankfurt
du kannst davon ausgehen wenn du dich im Bahnhof stellst
innerhalb der nächsten Viertelstunde kommt halt irgendwas
dann werden das auch viele machen
also ich kenne das von mir
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass es vielen ähnlich geht
es ist nicht so dass die Leute richtig Bock haben nach Frankfurt zu fahren
also ja
ich sehe das auch so
aber das heißt nicht
das heißt nicht dass man die Straßen
nicht trotzdem in Schuss halten muss
es gibt so viele Dinger mit Schlag
hier gibt bei mir in der Ecke
da bin ich schon mal fast rum und bin schon fast aufs Maul gefallen
morgens letztens als ich da
als ich da lang gerannt bin hab ich geguckt
ich hab nach vorne, ich hab grad ausgeguckt
nicht großartig auf die Straße
und da war ein mega Schlagloch
und das war auch noch ein künstliches Schlagloch
das war irgendein Schlagloch was sie nicht zugemacht haben
und nichts drum herum gestellt haben
das war so ein viereckiges
das war so ein fünf Zentimeter tiefes Schlagloch
bin ich reingetreten mit dem Fuß so halb auf die Kante
und bin fast aufs Maul gefallen
also die Straße muss trotzdem in Schuss gehalten werden
aber ja
ich stimme zu
hab ich jetzt das Richtige angekriegt beim Ausbau
ja okay stimme ich zu
Betriebe in, oh das ist jetzt eine Frage für mich
Betriebe in Hessen die nicht ausbilden
sollen eine Abgabe zahlen müssen
das Ding ist
also eine Abgabe
das ist wieder sowas
fällt hier nichts anderes mehr ein
es sollte attraktiv sein
Ausbildungsstellen anzubieten
aus welchen Gründen auch immer
offensichtlich ist es nicht attraktiv genug
weil die Leute sagen zwar
wir suchen wie verrückt
Fachkräfte aber ausbilden
wollen wir nicht
und ich glaube nicht
dass
eine Strafe dafür
geeignet ist
mehr
und bessere Ausbildungs
Stellen zu schaffen
ich weiß nicht
woran es hakt dass so viele Unternehmen
die könnten nicht ausbilden
ja
so nach dem Motto
wir suchen wie verrückt Leute
die unser Excel Zeug zusammen klicken
ja aber keine Physis ausbilden
nein ich denke nicht
dass die eine Abgabe bezahlen sollten
zumal
Betriebe ist ja super
weird ich meine da müsste ich auch ausbilden
ich bin eine Ein-Mann-Firma
ja also wenn man das
sagt ok das ist keine Ahnung
ein 200-Mann-Laden da könnte man
sich das vielleicht schon überlegen
soll ich mir ein Azubi hinsetzen
oder was
wie soll das funktionieren
nicht mal eine Rückmeldung erhalten
das gehört sich nicht
keine Rückmeldung zu schreiben
und sei es nur
die wollen dann halt keinen
und kriegen halt auch keinen
haben sie halt Pech
nein also ich denke nicht
dass sie eine Abgabe bezahlen müssen
genau das ist
zu pauschal alles
Moment was
der Wolf-Bestand
in Hessen soll begrenzt werden
gibt es Probleme
mit dem Wolf-Bestand in Hessen
ja genau
gibt es etwa zu viele
keine Ahnung
Hessen
Wolf-Problem
Stress mit dem Wolf
mehr Tiere und Konflikte in Hessen
deutlich mehr Nutztiere
was heißt deutlich
mehr Nutztiere
von Wölfen getötet
die Zahl der Wölfe
der Wölfen getötet
ist dieses Jahr deutlich gestiegen
mit 13
das ist ja nix oder
ich will nicht davon ausgehen
das 13 Angriffe
von wie viel war es
letztes Jahr noch
nur bis März
ach guck mal hier
nachgewiesene Wölfe
in Hessen
doch ganze 20
Nachgewiesene. Nachgewiesene.
Boah, ich weiß nicht.
In Hessen leben drei Wolfsrudel.
Gut.
Ganz ehrlich, Wolfbestand
soll begrenzt werden. Heißt ja nicht
zwangsläufig, dass man jetzt alle
Wölfe... Ich hab keine Ahnung, Leute. Ich mach neutral.
Ich kenn das...
Ich hab mich mit dem Problem nicht beschäftigt.
Kann durchaus sinnvoll sein.
Je nachdem, wie akut das ist. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
In hessischen Schulen
sollen sprachliche Formen
genutzt werden, die neben männlich und weiblich
auf weitere gestellt werden. Oh ne. Damit...
Damit will ich nicht anfangen.
Sonst kommt
demnächst irgendwas dazu.
Ja, aber mein
super spezial Ding,
was ich mit morgen ausgedacht hab, wird nicht
abgedeckt. Ganz ehrlich.
Es ist in der Schule
schon beschissen genug, wenn man
sich damit auseinandersetzen muss, wie man Sachen schreibt.
Und wenn da jetzt noch Wert drauf gelegt
wird, dass das neutral ist.
Wenn teilweise Sachen doppeldeutet.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube nicht,
dass das so sinnig ist. Wenn sich das
mal irgendwann wirklich breit durchsetzt,
dass man sagt, okay, 80%
der Leute... Keine Ahnung.
Ist ja ein fließender...
Fließendes... Wie soll man sagen?
Progress. Fließender Progress.
Also wenn das mal sich abzeichnet,
dass das ein Großteil der Leute eh macht,
dann
sollte man das dann vielleicht auch nach und nach
in den Schulen unterbringen.
Aber jetzt so mit der Brechstange,
weiß ich nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Ne, ich glaube nicht.
Verstehe nicht. Also, warum
sich manche Leute da so extrem reinsteigern,
verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht.
Das ist eigentlich eines der unsinnigsten
Diskussionen, die es gibt.
Ich finde es in manchen Stellen
sehr
hinderlich. Wir hatten letztens...
Letztens hatte ich ein gutes Beispiel.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern?
Wir hatten eine Webseite, die hat
ich glaube,
smarte Tafeln für Lehrer hergestellt.
Und ich musste
das fünfmal lesen,
bis ich gecheckt habe, was die
eigentlich machen.
Weil da stand dann sowas,
ein Produkt
von Lehrenden
für Lehrenden.
Irgendwie so ganz komisches Ding.
Ich hab das ohne Schein... Ich musste das fünfmal lesen,
bis ich es gecheckt habe, dass die
sagen wollten, das ist ein Produkt,
was von Lehrern
für Lehrer gemacht wird. Ich hab's nicht
kapiert. Ich hab's... Das erste Mal
hab ich es gelesen und dachte, die meinen ein Produkt
von Lehrern für Schüler.
Und irgendwann hab ich...
Okay, ihr
meint quasi
Lehrern für Lehrkörper.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass
man das in der Schule machen sollte.
Zumal es ja noch nicht mal klar ist,
wie das dann gemacht wird.
Mit Slash,
mit Minus, mit Sternchen.
Nur inklusive
Wörter. Ich weiß nicht.
Wenn sich da irgendwas etabliert hat,
dann kann man gucken,
wie man das in der Schule unterbringt,
wenn das relevant ist. Aber aktuell
eher nicht. Also,
ich bin der Meinung, ja. Ich geb dir
beim ersten Satz recht. Man sollte den Leuten
schon beibringen, ein gewisses
Mitgefühl und Respekt seinen
anderen Menschen gegenüber
aufzubringen. Da bin ich voll dabei.
Man muss aber auch mal
den Leuten teilweise ein bisschen nahe legen,
dass man nicht wegen jedem Furst
sich verletzt fühlen muss. Guck mal auf Twitter.
Da schreibt irgendwie
einer was Blödes und
20.000 Leute sind am Hyperventilieren
und sind kurz vorm Umkippen vom Rechner,
weil da irgendeiner mal irgendwo was geschrieben hat,
was ihnen persönlich nicht gefällt.
Also, man sollte
sich generell mal ein bisschen
entspannen und
sich nicht wegen jedem Scheiß des Todes
aufregen. Aber bei dem
ersten geb ich dir ganz recht.
Es schließt sich ja auch nicht aus.
Ich denke, die Leute sollen sich
frei entfalten. Die sollen alle machen, was sie wollen.
Vollkommen okay. Aber
trotzdem muss
man sich nicht wegen jedem Scheiß
gleich
übelst angegriffen fühlen.
Twitter, ja.
Twitter ist immer top dafür.
Aber man sieht, das ist ein hitziges Thema,
weil im Chat
ist das ja auch
anscheinend etwas umstritten.
Also ich bin ja mein in der Schule Muster.
Ist auf jeden Fall noch zu früh.
Ich meine,
es ist noch nicht mal klar,
in welcher Form das passieren soll.
Und selbst,
wenn du dich auf eine einigst,
willst du alle Möglichkeiten?
Selbst wenn du dich auf eine einigst,
also ich weiß nicht,
ob das in der Schule so sinnig ist.
Also ich stimme nicht zu.
Lass die Leute das
doch machen, wie die Schule. Das spricht ja auch
nichts dagegen. Ich habe gesagt,
es soll jeder machen, wie er will,
was seine persönliche Entfaltung angeht.
Wenn ich heute Gatschibass
machen will, kann ich das machen.
Und das geht glücklicherweise aktuell
2023 so gut wie noch nie
zuvor. Kann jeder machen,
was er will. Dass die Schule nicht unbedingt
immer was mit freier Entfaltung zu tun hat, sind wir uns
glaube ich einig. Da musst du halt
manchmal machen, was gemacht werden muss.
Auch wenn du keinen Bock drauf hast.
Hat mich ja auch übelst abgefuckt.
Deswegen fand ich es immer so bescheuert,
wenn die Leute früher gesagt haben, so nach dem Motto,
Max, wenn du mal aus der Schule kommst,
dann wirst du dich doch wünschen,
wenn du mal arbeiten musst nach der Schule,
dann wirst du dir wünschen, wieder in die Schule zu gehen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist, Leute. Habt ihr euch
nach der Schule und als ihr angefangen
habt zu arbeiten jemals gewünscht,
wieder in die Schule zu gehen? Also ich nicht.
Ich bin froh, dass dieser
Kack vorbei ist.
Mein Opa hat das immer erzählt.
Mein Opa hat auch immer erzählt,
mein Opa hat auch
immer erzählt,
ähm,
wenn du mal in die Schule kommst,
dann wirst du schwer Kordel nachgeben müssen.
Wenn du mal in die weiterführende
Schule kommst, dann wirst du schwer...
Wart mal ab, bis du eine Ausbildung machst,
dann wirst du schwer Kordel nachgeben.
Und wenn du richtig arbeiten gehst,
dann wirst du normal schwer Kordel...
Das hat sich ja immer nur ein bisschen verschoben.
Also, was haben wir als nächstes?
Die 5%-Hürde
für den Einzug in den Hessischen Landtag
soll beibehalten werden.
Also, wisst ihr, was ich cool finden würde?
Wisst ihr, was ich mega nice finden würde?
Wenn es
eine
Backup gäbe.
Also, zum Beispiel,
ich gebe
der Partei Primesub für Wubblors
meine Stimmen.
Sollte Primesub für Wubblors
allerdings nicht über 5%
kommen,
dann kann ich eine Backup-Stimme auswählen,
wer die dann bekommt.
Das fände ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Ich hab mir das aber noch nicht
genug durchdacht, ob das nicht
irgendwelche Nachteile hätte, dass man dann taktisch
nur noch kleinere wählt oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ich finde, das klingt erstmal ganz gut.
Vielleicht ist es aber auch
eine doofe Idee.
Vielleicht ist es auch eine doofe Idee.
Aber,
dass es eine gewisse Hürde gibt
in den Landtag, ist, glaube ich,
nicht verkehrt.
Ob die jetzt 5% sein muss?
Ich glaube,
manche Sachen muss man nicht unbedingt ändern,
also wenn das wirklich
so,
wie sagen wir,
überwiegend, nee, wie heißt das
auf Steam immer, wenn die Spiele gut bewertet
sind? Overwhelmingly positive.
Also wenn es
so übertrieben gute
Gründe dafür gibt, so nach dem Motto, hey,
das wäre das allerbeste
aus dem, okay, dann vielleicht,
aber das ist was Etabliertes,
wo sich die Leute in gewisser Weise auch dran
gewöhnt haben. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist,
das zu ändern.
Ich mach mal neutral.
Die Sache ist halt die, wenn man jetzt sagt,
5% Hürde ist zu hoch,
dann muss man sich wieder auf irgendwas,
das ist halt etabliert, dann muss man sich auf irgendwas einigen.
Das gibt dann wieder riesenlange Diskussionen.
Die einen wollen 3, die anderen wollen 4,
dann kommen dann wieder welche, die sagen,
nee, wir wollen eigentlich, aber 4 ist zu hoch, wir wollen
3,875
und dann bleibt es doch 5
am Ende. Ich mach neutral.
Keine Ahnung.
Sozialwohnungen sollen vorrangig an Deutsche vergeben
werden. Es wäre
nice, wenn es erstmal ordentlich
Wohnraum für die Leute generell gäbe.
Man sollte vielleicht gucken, dass es
ordentlich Wohnraum gibt.
Ob das jetzt vorrangig Deutsche kriegen?
Ich mein,
meine Nachbarn zum Beispiel, auf der einen
Seite sind keine Deutsche,
wobei dann, naja, muss man jetzt
aufpassen. Mittlerweile schon,
glaub ich zumindest.
Da bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht
so sicher, ob das der
Fall ist. Glaub ich zumindest.
Da würd ich jetzt auch sagen,
warum sollte man dem keine Sozialwohnung
geben, wenn er da irgendwie Probleme bekommt.
Es wäre natürlich
cool, wenn es generell immer ordentliche Wohnungen
geben würde. Ich mein, guckt euch mal Berlin
an. Berlin ist ja eh immer ziemlich abgefuckt
bei allem. In Berlin
erinnere ich mich noch
dran, wurde vor ein paar Jahren erzählt,
so nach dem Motto
Wohnraum ist viel zu
teuer.
So, und da gab es jetzt zwei Varianten, so nach dem
Motto, entweder
die bekommen ihren Arsch hoch
und bauen mal ordentlich, wie verrückt,
halbwegs bezahlbare Wohnungen
oder wir machen irgendwie so einen komischen Mietpreis
Deckel. Und man hat sich damals
dafür entschieden,
wir machen lieber so einen komischen Mietpreis Deckel.
Weil damals schon ganz viele gesagt haben, okay,
das wird genau das Gegenteil bewirken,
nämlich absolut keinen Anreiz mehr, neue Wohnungen
zu bauen.
Scheint nicht so gut funktioniert zu haben.
Also ich bin nicht der Meinung, dass man die
vorrangig unbedingt, dass das ein
Deutscher sein muss, der das kriegt.
Naja, ich stimme nicht zu.
Bei allen neuen Windkraftanlagen in
Hessen sollen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Anteile erwerben können. Ja, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Ich mein,
die Möglichkeit dafür
ist jetzt ja nix Schlechtes, oder?
Ach, geht's wieder da drum, dass es bei,
dass es, ja, das ist wieder sowas Pauschales.
Aber warum nicht?
Ja gut, okay.
Wenn ich mir, okay, wenn ich mir mal so recht
überlege,
wenn ich mir mal so recht überlege,
es sind ja nicht zwangsläufig
alle
Windparks,
jetzt, jetzt,
von irgendwelchen,
ja, wer baut denn Windparks?
Letztendlich bauen tun das natürlich
irgendwelche Bauunternehmen, aber wer
betreibt die? Das sind ja nicht irgendwelche Städte
oder so, das sind ja meistens schon private
Unternehmen und denen sollte man eigentlich schon
freistellen,
ob sie Beteiligung da dran
verkaufen wollen oder
nicht. Also ich denke,
zwingen sollte man keinen, weil
im Zweifelsfall
sorgt das für genau das Gegenteil,
irgendwelche Zwänge, dass dann einfach keine
Windkraftanlagen mehr gebaut werden oder
weniger Anreiz besteht, Windkraftanlagen zu
bauen.
Also so diese, diese
Holzhammer-Methode ist meistens keine
gute Idee. Prinzipiell
finde ich die Idee gut,
dass man Anteile erwerben kann an
Windparks, jetzt
irgendwelche privaten Unternehmen zu irgendwas
verpflichten und zwingen,
was sie dafür nicht wollen, weiß ich nicht,
ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Aber dann, naja, können sie doch jetzt auch schon,
oder? Hält es ja keiner
von ab. Nee.
Stimme nicht zu. Ihr wisst doch,
der Markt regelt
das.
Das mehrgliedrige
Schulsystem, zum Beispiel Hauptschule,
Realschule, Gymnasium soll erhalten bleiben.
Warum nicht?
Ist vielleicht nicht
jeder Pfeifett genug fürs Gymnasium?
Und selbst wenn du eine Gesamtschule
hast, die haben ja dann trotzdem
da auch sowas.
So nach dem Motto
ein Kurs in Mathe für
Mittelgute,
für Sehrgute, für
Three-Heads.
Das teilt Menschen in Klassen ein.
Naja, ich würde
mal sagen, ihr Geburts-IQ teilt sie halt
in gewisser Weise schon für geistige
Leistungsfähigkeit ein. Das macht sie nicht
zu schlechteren Menschen.
Und dass Leute unterschiedliche
Stärken und Schwächen haben,
es gibt ja keinen
allgemein gültigen
IQ. Selbst das,
wenn man sich die Tests mal anguckt, beziehen sich
ja immer auf unterschiedliche Themenfelder.
Es kann durchaus
einer mega Pfeifett
in dem einen Gebiet sein
und total unfähig in dem anderen.
Du hast natürlich auch manchmal Leute, die sind einfach
Pfeifett und super ehrgeizig.
Ich finde, denen sollte man die Möglichkeit dazu bieten.
Aber wenn du so gut warst,
warum musstest du dann auf die Hauptschule?
Das ist doch eigentlich nichts...
Das Problem ist in dem Fall doch nicht, dass es
eine Hauptschule existiert,
sondern dass sie dich aus irgendwelchen Gründen
in die Hauptschule gesteckt haben, weil sie gedacht
haben, du bist, keine Ahnung,
zu unfähig, das auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Die Hauptschule
ist ja nicht das Problem,
sondern die Klassifizierung in dem Fall.
Das stimmt
schon.
Ich sehe da kein Problem drin
in dieser Unterteilung.
Gesamtschulen gibt es ja auch
und man kann seine Kinder ja auch auf die
Gesamtschule stecken, wenn man will.
Aber wie gesagt, selbst dort gibt es dann
unterschiedliche Kurse, aber da kann man einfacher
wechseln, da muss man nicht die ganze Schule wechseln.
Aber das umzustrukturieren,
Alter,
wir haben Probleme mit
kleinsten Furzaufgaben, die 50 Jahre dauern.
Das kriegen sie
nicht gebacken.
Ich stimme zu.
Die hessische Polizei soll mehr Befugnisse
zur Verfolgung von Hasskrim
im Leben nicht. Nein, stimme ich nicht zu.
Alter, alles was
in Richtung geht, wir brauchen
mehr Chatkontrolle,
mehr Entschlüsselungssachen,
mehr Befugnisse in irgendwelche
E-Mail-Postfächer reinzugucken,
mehr Einschränkung von Privatsphäre,
die können nicht mal.
Nein, die kriegen keine mehr Befugnisse.
Also,
es ist auch nicht mal Hasskriminalität als
solches. Generell
finde ich das immer fraglich.
So nach dem Motto, man nimmt halt
irgendwas, wo die meisten Leute zustimmen
und dann hat man irgendeine Regelung hintendran,
die auf sonst was angewendet wird.
Oh, nein.
Gibt's nicht.
Gibt nicht mehr Befugnisse.
Pflegende Angehörige sollen vom Land
einen Zuschuss zum Pflegegeld erhalten.
Das klingt zumindest auf den ersten Blick
erstmal sinnvoll.
Wenn Leute daheimbleiben oder
aus irgendwelchen Gründen auch immer,
um sich um die Angehörigen zu kümmern,
kann man das doch unterstützen.
Ich meine, ansonsten muss irgendein
Pflegedienst kommen, irgendwelche anonymen
Leute, die
überhaupt keinen wirklichen Bezug dazu haben,
öfters wechselnde Leute. Ist doch viel besser,
wenn das die Angehörigen machen. Ich meine,
früher war das fast normal,
dass sich die Angehörigen um die Oma gekümmert
haben. Und wenn man da noch ein bisschen...
Finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Sehe ich da
einen Negativpunkt jetzt nicht, Chat?
Ich finde, das klingt sinnvoll.
Ist teuer für den Steuermutz.
Das stimmt wohl.
Wie gesagt, habe ich am Anfang...
Ich hab's eh aufgegeben,
dass ich...
Ich hab's eh aufgegeben, dass
ich glaube, dass irgendjemand was in
meinem Interesse noch mal macht.
Für jede neu bebaute Fläche
soll eine gleich große...
Nein, das ist Blödsinn.
Ihr habt's glaube ich schon rausgehört,
dass ich, könnte man sagen,
pro Umweltschutz bin.
Auch bei den anderen Fragen.
Aber man muss das natürlich schon in irgendeiner Art
und Weise
ein bisschen mit Hirn machen und pauschale
Aussagen sind in der Regel blöd.
So nach dem Motto, hier, guck mal.
Du bist jetzt immer verpflichtet,
auch egal
was ist,
du musst jetzt da was hinbauen.
Was und wie und wo ist egal.
Das läuft dann im Endeffekt so raus,
dass dann so halbgare
Dinger gemacht werden.
Da wird dann irgendwo, was weiß ich, Moos
gepflanzt oder so, weil man sagen kann,
so eine neue Fläche ist begrünt oder irgendwas
in der Richtung.
Also solche pauschalen Dinger.
Aber was sollen die machen?
Ich mein,
wenn der... Angenommen,
sie bauen noch eine Startbahn an den Frankfurter Flughafen.
Sollen sie dann...
Sollen sie dann ein paar Häuser abreißen
hinpflanzen oder wie?
Also es wäre sehr sinnvoll,
mehr Wald zu pflanzen. Es wäre auch sehr sinnvoll,
nicht alles zuzupflastern,
mit irgendwelchen Stein und Beton
und zuzugießen. Wir haben zum Beispiel auch
im Ort einen Platz, früher ganz
normaler Platz mit
Bänken in der Mitte,
bisschen Bäume, sonst wie.
Und den haben sie vor
4-5 Jahren komplett
zugepflastert und dicht gemacht.
Und das haben sie großverkauft
als super krasse Innenstadt-Revolution.
Und jetzt ist keine Sau
mehr da, weil es einfach nur mega hässlich ist.
Also das pauschal finde ich
auch nicht sinnvoll.
An den Hochschulen des Landes soll weiterhin
zu militärischen Zwecken geforscht werden dürfen.
Das mag jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen kontrovers sein,
aber ich denke schon.
Man hat gesehen, dass die Welt nicht Friede, Freude,
Eierkuchen ist. Und das hat man gerade
innerhalb der letzten paar Jahre gesehen.
Und ich denke, dass wir da technologisch
ein bisschen was auf dem Kasten haben.
Wenn doch mal irgendeiner
der Länder meint, Deutschland ist
Kacke,
dann ist das nicht verkehrt.
An Hessens Schulen soll vorrangig das
traditionelle Familienbild Vater, Mutter,
Kind vermittelt werden.
Ich denke, es ist nichts
Verwerfliches dran,
prinzipiell das zu vermitteln,
was für 90% der Leute zutrifft.
Das heißt
allerdings nicht,
dass man alles andere komplett ignorieren
soll. Also ja, es ist
durchaus sinnvoll, das traditionelle Familienbild
zu vermitteln.
Es ist halt die Frage, wie das gemacht wird.
Das ist
so ein Ding, das würde ich ganz
pragmatisch halten.
Wenn ein Großteil der Leute
quasi nicht,
oder wenn ein Großteil des Lebens
der Bevölkerung nicht mehr auf
das traditionelle Familienbild
passt,
dann sollte man das auch
in die Schule mit einfließen lassen.
Ansonsten spricht da aus meiner Sicht
nichts dagegen.
Es sollte ja
durchaus erlaubt sein, in der Schule zu sagen,
hey, guck mal, für einen Großteil der
Bevölkerung ist es halt nun mal noch Vater, Mutter,
Kind. Und
es soll nicht heißen, dass man
nicht auch sich mit anderen
Sachen beschäftigen soll, dass man sagen kann, hey, guck mal,
in der heutigen Zeit ist das durchaus
nicht unüblich, dass Männer und Männer
zusammenleben und Frauen und Frauen zusammenleben
oder super krass
bang, bang, jeder mit jedem,
was auch immer. Also
keine Ahnung, wie man das...
Das ist natürlich auch eine Frage.
Wie ist das
überhaupt gemeint?
Ich kann es mir nur so vorstellen,
dass wenn es halt Unterrichtsmaterial
gibt,
wenn es halt Unterrichtsmaterial gibt,
so was weiß ich, Familie Müller
wohnt
in Frankfurt am Main,
hat einen Garten, der so und so groß ist,
wie groß ist
der Garten von Familie Müller?
Also, dass eben in dem
normalen Unterrichtsmaterial sonst wie halt
da nicht drin steht,
das ist...
Keine Ahnung,
Max und
Stefan oder so, sondern,
dass da halt drin steht, das ist
Sonja und Michael oder so
im Unterrichtsmaterial.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich das ist,
wo die meisten
Leute sich nach wie vor damit identifizieren
können, wenn es bei ihnen daheim so ist.
Ach, was auch immer, kein Bock.
Das Land soll
einen Höchstsatz für die von der Kommune
erhobenen Grundsteuer festlegen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, ich persönlich,
da mir ein Haus gehört,
ja, sagen wir mal, da mir ein Haus gehört,
finde ich das immer gut,
sobald ich sicher
ist, dass ich nicht mehr Geld bezahlen muss.
Ich weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Das Land Hessen soll Projekte zur
Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus
verstärkt fördern.
Okay, jetzt kommen die AfD-Check-Fragen
wahrscheinlich.
Was der Chat sagt.
Können wir andere Musik anmachen?
Warum? Ist doch super entspannend.
Passt
vielleicht nicht unbedingt
zur harten Kost gerade.
Also ich fände das prinzipiell sinnvoll.
Ich fände es allgemein sinnvoll,
wenn man Projekte
gegen Extremismus, beziehungsweise gegen
irgendwelche menschenfeindlichen
und verachtenden Dinger fördert,
dann natürlich auch dagegen.
Also ich finde das an sich sinnig.
Für Führungspositionen von Landes
eigenen Betrieben soll es eine
verbindliche Frauenquote geben.
Warum?
Quoten sind meistens bescheuert.
Jetzt sollte derjenige
den Job kriegen, der am besten dafür qualifiziert
ist.
Nein.
Und jetzt kommt bestimmt gleich wieder einer mit
Aber das Patriarchat sorgt dafür,
dass für die industrielle
Nutzung von Grund- und Flusswasser
soll wieder eine Abgabe eingeführt werden.
Ist das nicht so?
Also
können wir aktuell einfach aus
irgendeinem Fluss was rauspumpen und ich muss
dafür nichts bezahlen?
Moment mal, ich könnte mir jetzt eine Meinung
Moment mal, ich könnte mir jetzt eine Leitung zum Main
legen und da einfach
Wasser abpumpen von, wenn ich
Bock drauf habe.
Stimmt, ich bin ja keine
Industrie, ja klar.
Aber bin ich, ich habe
eine Firma, bin ich nicht auch Industrie?
Genehmigung brauchst du.
Also ganz ehrlich,
wenn genug Grund-
und Flusswasser da ist,
wo ist das Problem,
dass die das nutzen?
Also,
muss man denen das Leben irgendwie schwer machen?
Ja, wenn nicht mehr genug da ist,
kann man es ja immer noch anders überlegen.
Das Problem ist,
dass du Geld bezahlst und die bekommen es for free.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das das Problem ist.
Moment, Bauern kriegen das dann nicht, oder wie?
Bauern sind
keine Industrie, das ist ja interessant.
Siehste mal, Chat-Guild,
da habe ich sogar noch was gelernt.
Da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass zumindest mal
ein Bau- Moment, also, das heißt,
wenn ich jetzt irgendwie
Fenster
herstelle mit irgendwelchen
Maschinen oder so, dann bin ich Industrie
und darf dafür Wasser abpumpen und wenn ich
Bauer bin,
der massig Wasser braucht, dann
aber das ist doch...
Ehrlich gesagt ist mir das wurscht.
Wir machen weiter.
Ich muss mir nicht um alles Gedanken machen.
Chat, dazu
hätte ich jetzt mal kurz was sagen.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt,
in Deutschland ist gar nichts großartig gerutscht.
Ich glaube, die Leute sind
genauso bescheuert wie eh und je.
Es hat sich aber die öffentliche Wahrnehmung
extrem geändert.
Was jetzt zu was zählt?
Und...
Vieles ist bei weitem nicht so
klar, wie man das denkt.
Ich mache jetzt mal ein Beispiel
dabei, um jetzt mal von diesem
Rechts und Links und sonst was wegzukommen.
Machen wir mal ein Beispiel
für. Das ist eine Sache, die
ich bis heute nicht
in den Kopf
bekomme,
wie das zusammenpasst. Und zwar
während
zu den Zeiten, wo es darum geht,
dass Leute sich impfen lassen sollten.
Da wurde das so
hingestellt nach dem Motto, okay,
Leute, die sich nicht impfen lassen...
Und ich will jetzt keinem irgendwie zu nahe drehen,
ob er es macht oder nicht. Es kann jeder aus meiner Sicht, jeder
selbst entscheiden, wie er will. Aber da war so die,
sagen wir mal, die allgemeine
Wahrnehmung, Leute,
die sich nicht impfen lassen, sind
Schwurbler und irgendwie so ein bisschen rechts.
Und die anderen
sind brav und gut.
So, und da habe ich mir mal
überlegt, okay,
wenn ich mir mal so eine 90er-Jahre-Punk
überlege,
der fand zwei Sachen scheiße.
Der fand
Nazis scheiße
und der fand die Regierung scheiße.
So.
Und hätte ich dem gesagt,
ey, Alter, lass dich
impfen, weil die Regierung das gerne
hätte, der hätte mir aufs Maul gehauen.
So, und
da will doch keiner
sagen, dass die Typen rechts gewesen sind.
Und das
ist so ein Ding, das kriege ich nicht im Kopf,
wie man auf die Idee
kommt, dass solche Entscheidungen
irgendwie...
dass man das klar
immer so schön trennen kann,
das ist rechts und das
ist links. Wisst ihr,
wie ich meine? Das passt
in vielen Sachen einfach nicht.
Ey, dann erklär mal.
Ich...
Ja, dann...
Wie gesagt, das ist ein Beispiel, das kriege ich einfach
nicht im Kopf, wie das
zusammenpassen sollte. Du wirst mir noch
recht geben, dass diese Sache mit
das ist alles geschwurbel und das ist
eher Richtung rechts,
dass das so gewesen ist.
Dass man prinzipiell Leute, die das nicht
wollten, gleich mit
irgendwelchen Nazi-Geschichten
zusammengebracht hat.
Richtig! Das ist es doch!
Deswegen kannst du nicht sagen,
deswegen kannst du nicht sagen,
dass das in irgendeiner Art und
Weise jetzt was mit
Nazis und Recht zu tun hat. Das hat,
in dem Fall, hast du von allen
Lagern irgendwas dabei gehabt,
die fragwürdige Dinger gemacht haben.
Und das ist bei ganz vielen Sachen so.
Deswegen finde ich so dieses, ah, hier
schwurbelig, das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen rechts
und ah, aber das andere ist so ein bisschen links.
Ich glaube, das ist viel zu pauschal
in vielen Fällen. Ja.
Komisch, ne?
Komisch.
Ich weiß,
ich weiß, wie viele...
Das ist aber komisch. Und das ist
exakt das Gegenteil
von dem,
wie das auch was viele Bands
früher vertreten haben. Früher war das
fick das System,
Regierung scheiße,
Polizei scheiße, alles scheiße.
Denen lag es nichts
ferner, als
der Brave zu sein, wenn
einer sagt, lass dich impfen,
lass ich mich impfen.
Der hätte sich aus Prinzip nicht impfen lassen
damals.
Daran sieht man, dass du das gar nicht so pauschal
irgendwo hinstecken kannst, dass du
gerade dort aus allen
Richtungen Leute dabei hattest,
die das so gesehen haben.
Naja. Ja, aber dann
ist ja was anderes.
Egal, macht da draus,
was ihr wollt, das ist immer noch was, was ich so
im Kopf nicht zusammenkriege.
Bei hohen Mietschulden sollen
Zwangsräumungen weiterhin zulässig sein.
Mach mal mit dem Valomat weiter,
dass ich weiß, was ich
morgen wählen muss. Aber Chat,
wisst ihr, was ich ganz gut finde?
Morgen ist auch
Bayern. Aber Chat, wisst ihr, was ich ganz gut
finde bei euch? Wir haben ja hier
die ein oder anderen Leute, die die Sachen anders
sehen als ich, anders sehen als Unternehmer.
Zumindest rastet hier keiner komplett aus.
Okay. Also.
30. Oh, wir haben noch 8
Stück. Ähm. Bei hohen
Mietschulden sollen Zwangsräumungen weiterhin
zulässig sein. Ja. Bin ich
dafür? Ich mein,
irgendwie muss die Leute loswerden, die
keine Kohle bezahlen.
Das Haus gehört denen nicht. Das Haus
gehört dem Vermieter. Und wenn die ihrem
Mietvertrag nicht nachkommen, mit,
sagen wir mal, einem, wie soll man das nennen,
angemessenen Frist
und einem angemessenen
staatlichen Rahmen,
ja, als letzte Konsequenz
musst du die Leute rausschmeißen können.
Willst du für 10 Jahre kostenlos im Haus
wohnen lassen oder wie?
Ja. Find ich gut.
Darf weiter so sein.
Die Parteien sollen ihre
Listen zur Landtagswahl
in Hessen abwechselnd
mit Männern und Frauen besetzen.
But why?
Ich mein, guckt mal.
Das krankt ja schon
an ganz vielen Stellen.
Ist die Frage, haben die überhaupt,
wie ist das Verhältnis
in der Partei? Ja, haben die irgendwie nur,
haben die 70-30, sonst wie?
Haben die überhaupt genug
Mädels, die das wollen oder wie auch immer?
Warum stellt
man nicht die Leute auf, die,
wie soll man sagen, am beliebtesten
sind oder die besten
Aussichten darauf haben,
gewählt zu werden?
Wäre doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll.
Und zumal das ja jede Partei gerne machen darf,
die das für richtig hält.
Okay.
Gut, da kann man jetzt sagen,
wird natürlich nie passieren, wenn das Patriarchat
dort herrscht oder sowas.
Also.
Wenn überhaupt irgendwie
anteilmäßig, dass man
sich anguckt, okay, aber
selbst das krankt ja ein bisschen
daran, weil am Ende führt das dann dazu,
dass du irgendwelche kompletten, ich sag mal,
No-Names da hinsetzt,
was
nichts über die,
wie soll man sagen, die unbedingt zwangsläufig
die Qualität der Leute sagt,
aber du willst ja schon Leute aufstellen,
die die besten Chancen haben,
gewählt zu werden. Und wenn du irgendeinen
Typ da hinstellst, den die Leute kennen,
vielleicht mit dem was verbinden,
womit sie was anfangen können, oder irgendwelche super
No-Names, nur weil da jetzt irgendwelche Plätze hinmüssen,
keine Ahnung, ob das so sinnvoll ist,
nicht anteilmäßig an der
Bevölkerung, wenn schon anteilmäßig an den
Parteimitgliedern. Aber ich glaube,
man sollte denen einfach gar keine Vorschriften machen.
Man soll einfach das aufstellen,
was sie für am besten halten.
Alle Schülerinnen und Schüler, deren Muttersprache
nicht Deutsch ist,
sollen erst nach dem
ausreichende Deutschkenntnisse festgestellt
werden in den Regelunterricht übernommen.
Okay, das funktioniert ja schon mal nicht.
Wie willst du das machen? Willst du
dann Leute
irgendwie
in die erste Klasse bringen,
wenn sie drei Jahre älter sind als der Rest?
Oder mitten im Jahr,
Ende des Jahres, random,
wenn die das halbe Jahr verpasst
haben oder so? Das funktioniert nicht.
Du musst irgendwie dafür sorgen,
dass Leute nicht richtig Deutsch können.
Am besten, bevor sie in die Schule kommen, richtig Deutsch können.
Oder sie in irgendeiner
Art und Weise so schnell wie möglich beibringen.
Also ich...
Das ist echt eine schwierige Frage.
Also, ich...
Ganz ehrlich, Leute, ich glaube, so groß ist das Problem
gar nicht.
Okay, jetzt werden alle sagen, doch Max, das ist ein Riesenproblem.
Aber ich werde euch jetzt mal
eine Story... Ich kann es nicht anders erzählen.
Ich werde euch mal eine Story erzählen.
Wir hatten in der Klasse
jemand, der kam aus Costa Rica.
Eine. Eine. Ich glaube Tanja hieß die.
Das ist schon ewig her.
Aber die kam aus Costa Rica.
Die konnte an ihrem ersten Tag
in unserer Klasse kein Wort Deutsch.
Nach...
Keine Ahnung.
Monaten oder so.
War das Deutsch nicht perfekt?
Aber die kam klar.
Das ging
mega schnell.
Die hat sich aber auch Mühe gegeben.
Die hat abends Kurse besucht
und auch im Haushalt haben sie versucht,
hauptsächlich Deutsch... Also ich weiß nicht,
was man mitgekriegt hat.
Und die konnte nach einem halben Jahr
richtig...
Also ich will nicht sagen native,
aber die konnte richtig gut Deutsch.
Und die musste damals immer noch mit,
wenn die Eltern
irgendwas machen wollten,
weil die Eltern es überhaupt nicht
auf die Reihe geklickt haben.
Problem ist, wenn in der Schule mehr Schüler kein Deutsch können,
als die, die Deutsch können.
Ja, das ist wohl ein Problem.
Das ist aber eher ein Problem,
was du nicht so sehr
rein in der Schule fixen kannst,
sondern eher drumherum.
Ich stelle es mir
organisatorisch enorm schwer
vor,
wenn man es nicht macht.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktionieren soll.
Du kannst doch nicht wirklich...
Wann ist die erste Klasse? Sieben?
Fünf? Nee, sechs oder so.
Sechs oder sieben?
Du kannst doch da nicht irgendwie mit
neun oder so, irgendwie
zwei Jahre später
jemand in die erste Klasse bringen,
bis er dann... Das funktioniert doch nicht.
Also ich kann das immer
nur an den Beispielen festmachen.
Die eine aus Costa Rica
war nicht das eine. Wir hatten damals auch jemand
aus dem...
Nicht Kosovo? Wo war
vorm Kosovo damals Krieg?
Ähm...
Bosnien?
Da ging es doch auch voll ab.
Da hatten wir einen
aus... Ich glaube aus Bosnien?
Jugoslawien! Jugoslawien!
Jugoslawien. Ja, genau.
Aus der Ecke.
Der konnte auch kein Wort Deutsch,
bis er in die zweite Klasse gekommen ist.
Und hat auch mega schnell Deutsch gelernt.
Ja, bei uns war das halt so.
Die ganze, gesamte andere Klasse hat auch Deutsch gesprochen.
Und der sah sich da halt
den ganzen Tag der Sache ausgesetzt
und musste mehr oder weniger schnell
Deutsch lernen.
Das ist so ein Ding, wo ich echt keine klare Antwort
drauf hab.
Bedeutet...
Bedeutet, wenn jemand
nicht in den Regelunterricht geht,
dass er dann trotzdem
den Inhalt der jeweiligen
Jahresstufe
vermittelt kriegt
und noch
nebenbei Deutsch lernt?
Also was ich...
Also ganz ehrlich,
was sicherlich sinnvoller wäre,
wenn die das so machen würden,
wie die Leute damals bei mir in der Klasse.
Die gehen in die Schule,
lernen dort Deutsch
und lernen
mittags nochmal zusätzlich
Deutsch.
Das hat bei denen wunderbar funktioniert.
Das ist doch...
Das klingt doch eigentlich nach einem durchaus
sinnvollen Konzept, oder?
Die sollen erst mal Rust lernen.
Das stimmt. Blazingly fast.
Das ist Chat. Wir haben die Lösung gefunden.
Die lernen
erst mal Rust,
dann sind sie Blazingly fast und dann lernen sie
schneller Deutsch und alles andere.
Chat, easy.
Easy, wir haben es gelöst.
Ich glaube, wir sollten uns das mal irgendwie patentieren lassen.
Also ich weiß
wirklich nicht, was ich hier... was ich jetzt...
mache. Also ich finde,
dass Deutsch lernen schon eine essentielle
Sache ist. Also wenn wir das mal so auslegen,
wenn wir das mal so auslegen,
dass das hier bedeutet,
dass das so ist,
wie ich das gesagt habe,
die Leute kommen in die Schule, lernen dort Deutsch
plus lernen zusätzlich noch nebenbei
Deutsch, so wie das bei mir in der Klasse
mehrfach passiert ist und das hat gut funktioniert,
dann würde ich der Sache zustimmen.
Aber das ist
ja nicht so, weil sie kommen ja nicht in den
Regelunterricht. Also
da müsste ich eigentlich nicht zustimmen.
Ich check's nicht.
Weiß nicht. Neutral.
Oh.
Jetzt kommt die...
jetzt kommt die Kleberfrage.
Ich überspring
das. Ich sag nicht neutral, ich sag einfach
diese These überspringen.
Jetzt kommt die Kleberfrage.
Sitzblockaden
auf Straßen sollen weiterhin strafrechtlich
verfolgt... Ja.
Was vielleicht
einem nicht gefällt,
aber ja, denke ich
doch, dass das gemacht werden soll.
Warum sollten Sitzblockaden,
die gegen Auflagen
und Gesetze und Regelungen verstoßen,
auf einmal nicht strafrechtlich
verfolgt werden können, wohingegen
alles andere strafrechtlich verfolgt werden
kann?
Das macht ja keinen Sinn. Also ja.
Was nicht
heißt, dass man gleich den LKW holen soll
und so umfahren.
Weil das wird auch strafrechtlich verfolgt.
Die Hürde für
Volksentscheide in Hessen sollen gesenkt werden.
Wie die Schweizer.
Tschädtke, wir haben doch ein paar Schweizer
hier. Okay, ich weiß nur, dass
Herr Patrick Schweizer ist.
Wie...
wie... wie...
beliebt ist das denn in der Schweiz?
Also wie hoch
ist denn da so die Beteiligung bei Volksentscheiden?
Gehen die Leute da hin?
Oder ist das eher sowas, ah, da ist
halt was und
juckt mich eh nicht.
Meistens unter 40%.
Volksentscheide, sowas gibt's
in DE. Es gibt...
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das ein Volksentscheid
war. Es gab doch mal
eine Um... Es gibt ab und zu mal so Umfragen.
Es gab doch eine Umfrage, ob die Sommer-
und Winterzeit
Umstellung abgeschafft werden soll.
Und da haben irgendwie 80% für Ja gestimmt.
Aber es hat keinen danach
interessiert.
Jaja, die war EU-weit.
Also ehrlich gesagt,
ich würde in dem Fall neutral sein.
Ich überblicke da wirklich
nicht die Vor- und Nachteile.
Okay, was
haben wir noch? Das Verbot
öffentlicher Tanzveranstaltungen an Karfreitag
dem Volkstrauertag und
Totenson... Nö.
Kein Tanzverbot mehr.
Vielleicht komplett unsinnig.
Das ist eher eine Frage für die
Bayern. Bei denen ist das alles
super christlich.
Der öffentliche Personennahverkehr in Hessen
soll für alle entgeltfrei... Okay,
Leute, das ist so eine Frage, da würde ich natürlich
sagen, gefühlsmäßig
würde ich sofort sagen, yo!
Aber
realistisch betrachtet
wird das kaum machbar sein.
Und
im Endeffekt bezahlen wir es trotzdem.
Ich finde das
gut. 49 Euro Ticket
finde ich ist eine gute Sache. Man könnte sich jetzt drüber
streiten, ob man es nicht vielleicht noch ein bisschen billiger machen
sollte. Aber komplett
kostenlos
weiß ich nicht.
Also mal seriously,
ich kann euch sagen, in Frankfurt,
was passieren würde, wenn das kostenlos wäre.
Hauptbahnhof, die
Straßenbahn wäre voll mit den ganzen Bahnhof-
Assis. Die würden quer durch Frankfurt
fahren den ganzen Tag, gerade im Winter.
Weil da ist warm drinnen.
Dann willst du danach, wenn das
passiert in Frankfurt, willst du nicht
mehr in Straßenbahn einsteigen.
Im Winter dürfen sie so häufig so fahren.
Also in Frankfurt ist das so, ich weiß nicht,
ob die manchmal fahren.
Die haben im Winter in manchen
S-Bahn-Stationen, beispielsweise an der
Hauptwache,
wird abends
dann aufgeschlossen oder nicht
zugeschlossen für Obdachlose, dass die
abends nicht mehr fahren können.
Das finde ich auch eine sehr sinnvolle Sache.
Also ich glaube, entgeltfrei ist nicht
unbedingt der beste Ansatz dafür.
Erschwinglich,
also es sollte nicht übertrieben teuer sein,
deswegen, ich finde das, wir können vielleicht
sich überlegen, dass man sagt, das 49-Euro-Ticket
sollte ein bisschen billiger werden. Aber was ich
persönlich viel sinnvoller fände,
wenn das 49-Euro-Ticket
auch wirklich
in dem Rahmen bleibt und nicht
irgendwie in drei Jahren das 89-Euro-Ticket
ist, weil dann haben wir die normalen,
also wisst ihr, wenn wir in ein paar Jahren
bei einem normalen Monatsticket
wieder angelangt sind, dann hat es das ja auch
nicht gebracht. Also ich glaube,
kostenlos ist
enorm schwierig umzusetzen
und kostet enorm viel Geld.
Der Vorteil wäre,
dem mir gerade auch noch einfällt, ich glaube,
es wäre verwaltungsmäßig relativ easy.
Du brauchst kein
wer sammelt wo das Geld
irgendwie ein und wer muss wohin,
sondern kannst einfach einsteigen, gut wäre.
Also ich würde
tatsächlich, auch wenn ich
ÖPNV-Fan bin
und die Bahn gerne fliege, würde ich in dem Fall sagen,
ich weiß nicht, ob das so die allerbeste Idee ist.
Ich werde mal nicht zustimmen.
Das...
Schon wieder!
Das Landesamt für Verfassungsschutz ist aber oft
dabei.
Das Landesamt für Verfassungsschutz soll die
NSU-Akten vollständig der Öffentlichkeit
eröffnen. Sind sie nicht?
Warum nicht?
Warum?
Warum sind sie das nicht?
In Hessen
soll es mehr Verkaufs...
In Hessen soll es mehr
verkaufsoffene Sonntage geben.
Unbedingt! Ich finde es nice, wenn man
sonntags einkaufen kann.
Scheiße für die, die den Kackjob machen
müssen. Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Nein, ich bin Wubblers!
Doch, ich finde das gut.
Kann ich sonntags im Supermarkt
was einkaufen?
Ich finde das mega...
Doch, ich fände das richtig nice.
Aktuell, wenn du arbeiten gehst
und einkaufen musst, musst du das entweder
abends nach der Arbeit machen, was übelste Abfuck ist,
oder Samstag, wenn das alle machen.
Ich fände das geil, wenn das sonntags
öfters... öfters
offen wäre. Und an der Gelegenheit
auch die Post noch sonntags
kommen lassen.
Müssen die halt mehr Leute
einstellen, ist mir doch egal. Ja, ich finde das geil.
So, Gewichtung.
Die Leute
werden dann dazu gezwungen...
Naja, es gibt
ja nach wie vor Arbeitszeitregelungen
und Gesetze. Die werden
mehr Leute einstellen müssen.
Oh, mein
Videoplayer ist gerade abgekackt.
Also, Gewichtung der Thesen.
Wir gewichten hier gar nichts. Wir lassen das
jetzt einfach so. Weiter zur Auswahl
der Parteien. Wir machen es uns einfach...
Ja, wir wählen einfach alle aus.
Wen gibt's denn da eigentlich
alle so?
CDU, Grüne, Hessen,
AfD, Freie
AfD, FDP,
die Linken, okay, die kennt man. Freie Wähler
Hessen. Ich kenn die Freien Wähler nur
aus Bayern.
Was Partei
ergreifen... Moment, wie heißen die?
Partei ergreifen Mensch,
Umwelt, Tierschutz. Okay, die Part...
Die Partei gibt's auch noch. Die Parti...
Was, die Piratenpartei gibt's auch noch.
ÖDP, die hab ich früher ein paar Mal
gewählt, vor Jahren. Danach sind
die Kompletten der Versenkung verschwunden,
weil's die einzigen waren, die Internetausbau
und sowas irgendwie auf der Liste hatten,
also im Programm hatten damals.
Partei für...
Partei...
Wat?
Partei für schulmedizinische
Verjüngungsforschung.
What?
Ist das... Ist das irgendein...
Irgendein... Irgendeine Blödsinn?
Das meine ich ernst, oder?
Der Name
ist ja zu geil, Alter.
Partei für schulmedizinische
Verjüngungsforschung.
Okay, wen haben wir dann sonst noch?
Die V-Partei hoch...
Hoch 3?
Oder die Kubik...
Die Kubik-V-Partei.
Dann haben wir die Partei der Humanisten.
Dann haben wir...
Aktionenbürger für Gerechtigkeit.
Dann haben wir die Pogo-Anarchisten.
Die Basis...
Der Name ist ja zu...
Die Anarchistische
Pogo-Partei Deutschlands.
Die ABPD.
Deutsche Kommunistische... Ah!
Die dürfen natürlich auch nicht fehlen.
Gekommerzt am Staat.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass wir sowas haben.
Bliat.
Die neue Mitte haben wir noch.
Volt.
Und die Klimaliste Hessen.
Für unser Haus.
Weiter zu ihrem...
Okay, Chat. Ratet mal...
Okay.
Ratet mal die Top 3, wo ich lande.
Was sind meine Top 3 in der
Liste? Also, ich denke,
die FDP ist tatsächlich relativ weit oben.
Da gehe ich auch für...
Da gehe ich tatsächlich von aus.
FDP, AfD, CDU,
FDP.
SPD glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht,
dass sie so weit oben ist. Aber man weiß es ja nie.
Nicht, dass ich einen großen Plan
hätte, welche Partei
für was ist.
Vielleicht ist ja auch die
Pogo-Anarchisten dabei.
SFDP,
SSH und UDP.
Also, weiter zum Wahl-O-Mat-Ergebnis.
Pause, Champ!
FDP.
Ihr habt recht, Chat.
Ich muss sagen, das deckt sich
auch tatsächlich.
Der Markt regelt das, ja.
Das deckt sich
allerdings tatsächlich auch oftmals
tatsächlich mit meinen Ansichten.
Und...
Ich habe bei der letzten Wahl
auch FDP gewählt.
Ob ich das morgen wieder machen werde, weiß ich auch nicht so genau.
Also, Moment. Nicht bei der letzten
Wahl, sondern auf Bundesebene.
Ist das
aus dem Weg-Geringverdiener-Video?
Nee, doch nicht. Irgendwas
dachte ich mir, dass das jetzt kommt.
Okay, dann haben wir die Freien Wähler
am Start. Die CDU,
die PHD, weiß gar nicht, wer das ist.
Ach, das sind die Humanisten.
Kommt die AfD, die Neue Mitte,
Piraten, Partei für
Schulmedizinische Verjüngungsforschung.
Die Pogo-Anarchisten.
Okay, die Grünen
sind 54.
Die Linken sind ganz unten.
Wo ist die SPD? Okay, naja.
Also,
bin ich ja wieder mal bestätigt.
Bin ich mal wieder bestätigt.
Werde ich auch morgen FDP wählen. Easy.
Stimmt, wo ist die
Tierschutzpartei?
Da ganz unten, 43%.
Die haben mich tatsächlich schon mal
gewählt, die Tierschutzpartei.
Da habe ich irgendwann
mal vor dem Wahlzettel
gesessen und hatte gar keine Ahnung.
Da habe ich die Tierschutzpartei
gewählt, weil ich mir dachte, die schaffen sie
nicht. Tut einfach
weh, die AfD zu sehen.
Ja, was willst du machen? Auch die
AfD hat vielleicht mal ein paar ganz sinnvolle Punkte.
Wenn auch viel Schwachsinn dabei ist
oder viele Sachen, die ich im Leben nicht unterschreiben würde.
Und wenn sich die paar
sinnvollen Punkte vielleicht auch mit meinen sinnvollen Punkten
decken, dann steht halt die AfD
da. So ist es halt.
Ich meine, es hat jetzt da irgendwie
keinen Sinn, sich da irgendwie groß Gedanken
drüber zu machen. Ich habe das angeklickt,
was ich für sinnvoll halte und das muss jeder für
sich selbst entscheiden.
Also sprich,
ich werde euch da auch nix irgendwie erzählen
sonst wie. Ihr habt jetzt gesehen, was ich machen
werde, beziehungsweise ob ich morgen
FDP wähle, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich schon.
Aber letztendlich
wählt das,
was ihr für richtig haltet.
Egal, was es hier von ist.
Und das sage ich
extra so neutral, auch wenn es vielleicht manche
aufregen wird. Wählt das, was ihr für
richtig haltet. Das ist eure Stimme.
Und das,
wovon ihr denkt,
dass die am besten
eure Ansichten und das, was ihr gerne
hätten, haben,
wollt, vertreten wird.
So.
Nur zwei Minuten, please.
Oh ne.
Da hab ich jetzt kein Nerv drauf.
Nein.
Sag nix. Trotz Mod gibt Bonus.
Guck ich mir jetzt nicht an.
Also die Bekundung gucken wir uns jetzt
nicht an, weil
ich muss jetzt gleich pennen. Ich bin so
krass im Arsch, nach den 50
Kilometer, 51 Kilometer Fahrradfahren heute.
Wie macht sich die
GoPro? Die hatte ich heute nicht dabei.
Keine GoPro.
NickBNX,
danke für den Sub. Okay.
Chatki, wir haben es geschafft.
Der Markt regelt das schon.
Und das war jetzt, bis zur
nächsten Wahl, mein einziger
Stream, der irgendwas mit
Politikbezug ist.
Weil das Internet meistens
ein ungünstiger Ort
dafür ist.
Wenn man nicht quasi
genug Leute hat, die ins gleiche Horn blasen.
Die Richtung ist fast egal.
Aber solange man sich da in seiner eigenen Blase
bewegt, kann man das natürlich auch jeden Tag machen.
Gibt ja genug
Leute, die
sich öfters auf Twitch
mit kontroverseren Themen auseinandersetzen.
Ah, da habe ich
keinen Nerv drauf.
Zumal ich auch ehrlich zugeben muss,
dass ich auf viele Themen
absolut keinen Bock habe, mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Und deswegen,
um das nochmal Bezug zu nehmen,
was ich am Anfang gesagt habe, letztendlich
ist mir das eigentlich fast wurscht, weil
ich habe eh die Hoffnung aufgegeben,
dass irgendwann mal einer was in meinem Interesse
macht.
Können es auch sein lassen.
Ich rate
jetzt irgendwelche
Anime-Girl-VTuber-
Pool-Streams gleich.
Was wäre denn dein
Interesse? Ich sag doch
VTuber-Anime-Pool-Grills.
Man of
Culture.
Hatten wir nicht mal sogar einen Pool?
Moment, Chat.
Hatten wir nicht sogar mal einen Pool-Keks
irgendwo hier?
Seht ihr es irgendwo?
Ah, hier!
Und ich glaube, wir hatten sogar
ein paar Sensoren dafür.
Okay, Chat, geh.
Ich geh jetzt pennen.
Okay, Chat.
Für alle Man of Culture,
für alle
Man of Culture, was haben wir denn
hier kurz?
Was haben wir denn heute hier Schönes?
MonkaToss. Es kann nicht MonkaToss sein.
Das sind offizielle Twitch-Streams.
Da kann nichts passieren, okay?
Aha, aha.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Ah! Exzellenter Stream.
Pool-Stream.
Habt ihr mal mitbekommen,
dass die letztens, also
letztens ist nun wirklich...
Da ist der Fisch aus.
Habt ihr mitbekommen,
dass letztens und letztens ist
wirklich sehr,
sehr dehnbar?
Ihr wollt nicht
die Fische haben, ja?
Also letztens ist wirklich
ziemlich lange her.
Aber habt ihr mitbekommen,
dass
irgendwelche koreanischen
Pool-Streamerinnen
gebannt wurden,
weil sie
sich live on stream
umgezogen haben und die eine noch
zur Hälfte im Bild war?
Ich hab auch gedacht, wie blöd kann man sein, ja?
Wenn man schon halb nackig
vor der Kamera steht und sich dann ganz nackig macht,
dann kann man auch aus dem Kamerabild gehen.
Haben wir noch...
Ah ne, Moment, das war was anderes.
Brauchen wir das? Okay, wenn wir das brauchen,
kann ich das mal hinzufügen.
Kannst du uns das kurz respektvoll zeigen?
Ihr könnt es respektvoll
euch selbst angucken.
Okay, Chat, dann
gehe ich jetzt mal
auf. Kommst du morgen an? Ja, morgen
wieder wie gehabt.
Morgen bin ich am Start.
9 Uhr.
8.30
bis 9.
Also geht's los. Ich bin nicht
8.30 bis 9 am Start, sondern
ich fang an.
8.30 bis 9.
Also bis denn,
Leute, macht's gut.